AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
WEBER MEMBERS.
AYE MARCHING HOSHINO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL COUNCIL I
HAVE WITH ME.
THE HONORABLE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF THE LA SUPERIOR COURT A DAN
BUCKLEY. THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME INTRODUCE YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE CAME HERE THIS.
AVENUE WHERE YOU BEGAN I'M NOT
ESTABLISH QUORUM.
AND THEY WILL LET YOU CONTINUE
WITH WOMEN GET WE GOT TO DO IT
OKAY ABSOLUTELY.
US SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE A WEBER HERE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY CARE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THANK YOU NOT COMMITTING TO HELP
ME PROVIDE THIS PRETTY.
RESPECTIVE
I THINK THE FIRST THING I WILL
BE BRIEF.
OWING TO THE THE THE CHALLENGES
OF THE OF THE OF THE.
CLOCK. DOCTOR WEBER BUTLER IN
THE OVER ARCHING THEME I THINK A
PERSPECTIVE I WANT TO PROVIDE IS
AT THE BUDGET AS IT IS PROPOSED.
REALLY REFLECTS WHAT WE FEEL IS
A CONSENSUS PRIORITY AMONG THE
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS THE
CHIEF JUSTICE HERSELF AS WELL AS
USUAL COUNSEL. A AS WELL AS OUR
TRIAL COURTS IN NAMELY IT IS
THAT THIS BUDGET REALLY REFLECTS
OUR TOP PRIORITY UNITS A
CONSENSUS PRIORITY. OF WHICH IS
THAT IT PROVIDES NEW FUNDING FOR
THE BASE OPERATIONS FROM A TRIAL
COURTS AND NOT JUST NEW FUNDING
BUT
EXPAND. AND OR CREATE NEW TYPES
OF SELF HELP SERVICES WHICH WILL
ADDRESS WHAT IS REALLY THE
FASTEST GROWING PUBLIC NEED.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN OUR COURTS IN CALIFORNIA THE
SECOND COMPONENT A IS
APPROXIMATELY FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
TO FURTHER THE EFFORT TO
EQUALIZE FUNDING AMONG OUR
INDIVIDUAL TRIAL COURTS AND WE
ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT IN TIME
THAT THAT PROPOSAL WOULD BENEFIT
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR. OF OUR MOST
SEVERELY UNDER UNDER FUNDED THE
COURTS.
BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I
THINK MEMBERS BECAME AWARE OF
THAT WE WERE IN THE FIFTH AND
FINAL AND MOST DIFFICULT YEAR OF
A FIVE YEAR PROJECT. AT THE
COURT SYSTEM INITIATED WHICH WAS
TO SHIFT MONEY FROM SOME COURTS
TO OTHER COURTS THAT WERE SO
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED AND LAST
YEAR WAS A DIFFICULT YEAR IN
FACT IT'S THE CURRENT YEAR FOR
US IS A DIFFICULT YEAR BECAUSE
WE DID SO ABSENT NEW FUNDING.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT THIS YEAR TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE ADVANCE THE
EQUALIZATION OF FUNDING BUT TO
DO SO WITH NEW RESOURCES BUT
WHICH WE THINK WILL BE
INCREDIBLY ADVANTAGES TO ALL
COURTS IN THE SYSTEM AND THEN
LASTLY. THE THIRD COMPONENT LA
IS SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN DISCRETIONARY SPENDING.
THAT WAY LAW AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE
THAT.
THOUGH IT'S NOT QUITE A
COMPLETE OVERLAP IT WOULDN'T BE
A TOTAL ARE COMPLETE SOLAR OR
LUNAR ECLIPSE.
BUT THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PRIORITIES OF OUR CHIEF JUSTICES
THAT YOU JUST OR AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS WELL AS OUR
IS A TRIAL COURT'S.
AND SO WITH THAT I WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW OUR VIEW OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSAL. A AND WE HOPE
AS YOU WORK YOUR WAY THROUGH
YOUR DELIBERATIONS YOU WILL SEE
THAT IT WILL HELP. OUR COURTS
HELP WE DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LAW.
CENTER THE TOTAL LEVEL OF FUN
I WOULD LIKE TO
BY THE RELATIVE TO ITS GENERAL
FUND SPENDING PRIORITIES.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT TO
WHATEVER ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
PROVIDED BE PROVIDED BASED ON
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES SUCH AS
THAT THAT ARE SPECIFIED TOUCHES
PROGRAMS OR SERVICES OR A COLA
ADJUSTMENT WHAT WOULD BE IT.
RATHER THAN ALLOWING JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
AT THIS TIME IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE AUGMENTATION WOULD BE SPENT
BECAUSE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WOULD
HAVE COMPLETE FLEXIBILITY AND
USING THOSE FUNDS.
SO THE FUNDS COULD BE ALLOCATED
TO THE INDIVIDUAL TRIAL COURTS
ON WALL FROM AS HAS BEEN DONE
PREVIOUSLY.
OR IT COULD BE USED TO TO FIND
FUTURES COMMISSIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MENTIONED.
HOWEVER IT WITHOUT COSTS AND
BENEFITS FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW MANY AND TO
WHAT EXTENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
THE LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
IN REGARDS TO THE EQUALIZATION
FUNDING. EQUALIZATION CAN OCCUR
IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT IS A PRIORITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN SPECIFY HOW THEY
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
FINALLY THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS OF WHETHER
THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS CURRENT
WORKLOAD BASED METHODOLOGY
ACCURATELY ESTIMATES TRIAL
COURTNEY. AND SO WE DO
RECOMMEND.
CONVENING A WORKING GROUP TO
EVALUATE THE METHODOLOGY AND
OFFER POTENTIAL RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR CHANGE BY NOVEMBER FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AN ACCURATE FORMULA WOULD HELP
THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE THE
TOTAL LEVEL A FUNDING TO PROVIDE
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S ANNUALLY.
AS WELL AS HOW TO ALLOCATE FUNDS
TO ENSURE THAT TRIAL COURTS AND
MEET LEGISLATIVELY DESIRED
SERVICE LEVELS.
OKAY LIAM.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
COULD YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND.
WOULD BASICALLY JUST ASKED TO
GIVE A SURE.
QUIZZES XIN OF JUNE FAVOR ARE
OPPOSED TO THE RECOMMENDATION
CONCERNING THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION CONTAIN THANK YOU
DOCTOR.
MY NAME IS WHEN CARL ON THE
PRESIDING JUDGE OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
AND I JUST PURE TODAY TO SAY
THERE'S NO DAYLIGHT BETWEEN. THE
COURSE ADDITIONAL COUNSEL IN THE
CHIEF AND THE PARTNER FINANCE ON
THIS WE FULLY SUPPORT THE BUDGET
AS PROPOSED. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE BELOVED
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL THE
CIVIL DEFENSE BAR AND. A
DEPUTIZED BY NANCY TRAVELED ALSO
SPEAK FOR THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S UP BUDGET
PROPOSAL HERE FOR THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION. A THE CIVIL.
SYSTEM WAS PARTICULARLY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIT FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL REASONS DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT NEW OPPORTUNITY AND
WE THINK SOME RESOURCES WILL BE
DEDICATED. TO THE CIVIL SYSTEM
A WHICH IS SO CRITICAL TO
RESOLVING DISPUTES WE'VE HAD
TRIAL DELAYS.
THE DELAYS IN GETTING HEARINGS
BROUGHT TO TRIAL WHICH.
HAS REALLY SLOWED EVERYTHING
DOWN IN THE SYSTEM AND THIS IS A
CHANCE
TO BEGIN TO CATCH UP SO WE VERY
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL THINKING.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION WE
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ONE COPY OUT. AS LAID
OUT BY THE LA GO THAT THE
FUNDING BE DISCRETIONARY FOR THE
TRIAL COURTS TO DETERMINE HOW TO
BEST USE THOSE FUNDS. ON ALSO
HAVING SAID THAT WE THINK THIS
IS A VERY GOOD START BUT IS
STILL NOT ENOUGH FUNDING TO GET
THE COURTS REALLY WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE SO THEY CONCERT
CONSUMERS ON TIME. BEGINNING Q..
THAT AFTERNOON CARRYING CASE
THEREIS NOT A PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
AND THEY REPRESENT THE COURT
EMPLOYEES IN SACRAMENTO AND
MERCED AND ALSO THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY COURT EMPLOYEES.
ASSOCIATION I WANNA.
AGREE WITH WHAT MY OF MY
COLLEAGUE THE SOMEONE. I'M
SORRY.
.
ONE AGREE WITH MICHELLE CASTRO
FROM SEIU IN SUPPORT OF THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION AND THE LA
A RECOMMENDATION THAT THE FUNDS
BE ALLOCATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND NOT LEFT TO THE DISCRETION.
OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU.
MADAM CHAIR ABOUT THERE IS A
SECOND ITEM LINKED IN THE AGENDA
ON THE IT PROJECTS AND I WANTED
TO SPEAK ABOUT I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THAT SHOULD BE NOW. OR.
LATER AT SOMETIME.
AT.
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR COMMENT NOW
FATHER THANK YOU WE.
WERE VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED
BY A VARIETY OF THE COURT UNION
THE COURT THE UNIONS
REPRESENTING COURT EMPLOYEES.
ABOUT ASKING THAT THERE BE SOME
LIKELY STATE OVERSIGHT ON IT
PROJECTS YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THOSE CA BOTH THE CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT IT WAS
ESTIMATED AMOUNT CAME AND.
BILLION TIMES MORE THAN WHAT WAS
ESTIMATED AND THEN WE HAVE WE
SAW FIVE COURTS THAT.
STATE WITH VERSION THREE OF THAT
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ARE SAN
DIEGO IN SACRAMENTO WHERE TWO OF
THOSE COURTS.
SAN DIEGO ALONG WITH FOUR OTHER
COURTS VENTURA ORANGE AND SAN
JOAQUIN THEN THEY MOVED OUT AND
GROUP TOGETHER. TELL GET LIKE A
GROUP GOOD RATE ON THEIR ON STOP
WATCHING THEIR OWN REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM WHILE SACRAMENTO WAS
COMPLETELY OUT ON THEIR OWN. WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND AT ALL WHY THEY
WOULDN'T GO FOR SOME KIND OF.
BETTER PRICE WHEN YOU HAVE MORE
PEOPLE TOGETHER TRYING TO
PURCHASE THAT OF OUR COURT UNION
FEELS VERY STRONGLY THAT THE
COURTS. OF USE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND IT AS AN EXCUSE NOT TO
REALLY BARGAIN.
AS AS MUCH IN GOOD FAITH AS
WE'D LIKE SO WE WOULD REALLY
LIKE YOU TO ADOPT THE
RECOMMENDATION. THAT'S IN THE
BOOK THE COURT UNION A COALITION
LETTER ABOUT PUTTING STATE
OVERSIGHT ON IT THAT. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH MISS
CASTRO'S REMARKS. WE LIKE TO SEE
THIS MONEY GO BACK A TWO TRUCK
COURSE RECORD OPERATIONS IN
ORANGE COUNTY OF OUR COURT
REPORTERS ARE PART TIME.
THERE PART TIME IN THE COURTS
CLOSE EARLY AS A RESULT UP HERE
THE CLOSE AT FOUR FOUR FIFTEEN.
AND WE'VE ALSO LOST ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT OF OUR COURT REPORTERS
DUE TO THE LACK OF FUNDING GOING
TO OTHER COURTS AND WHAT NOT SO
IT'S A IT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
AN ORANGE COUNTY AND.
.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSH WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
COULD ECHO THE CALL THAT THE
DISCUSSION BE HELD LOCALLY IN
DETERMINING HOW THESE FUNDS
SHOULD BE EXPENDED. IN ADDITION
WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO EXAMINE. THE BACKLOGS THAT
MANY COURTS FACED IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE WAY TO ADDRESS THOSE
THROUGH ADDING ADDITIONAL
JUDICIAL ASSISTANCE COURT CLERKS
AND OTHERS. WHO CAN HELP GET
THROUGH THOSE BACKLOGS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE?
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAUREN
CLIMB AND WITH THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
LEGAL AID NON PROFITS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL LOW INCOME
PEOPLE HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME ACCESSING THE COURTS
WHETHER IT'S LACK OF COURT
REPORTERS CLOSED HOURS AND
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO THE
COURTS ALLOWS THEM TO OPEN.
OPEN UP MORE ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
IN NEED SUPER SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JIM
LOMBARD CHIEF DEPUTY OF THE
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT. AND
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WE ENCOURAGE THE. USE
OF FLEXIBILITY SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS NEEDS OF OUR LOCAL COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLINE DASHER
AND THE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION AND
I'M ALSO AN EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBER SEIU SEVEN TWO ONE. AND
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND ALSO I AGREE WITH
LA US OFFICE THAT IN NEEDS BE
DISCRETIONARY FOR THE TRIAL
COURTS THINKING THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND I'VE P. T. LOCAL
TWENTY ONE BOTH REPRESENT COURT
EMPLOYEES.
WE DO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
BUT WE ALSO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH THE COUNTY OUT THAT WHO I
LAID OUT BY SEIU.
ANY ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSAL.
ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COUNTLESS ALONE OKAY AND MISTER
LACKEY HE THE ONE.
BLITZER.
OKAY MUNJAL.
REAL SIMPLE JUST KIND OF A
CLARIFYING QUESTION.
WE'RE TALK ABOUT THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR FLEXIBILITY
AS PROPOSED.
WHO SPECIFICALLY WOULD DETERMINE
HOW THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE
DISPERSED?
WELL AS IT STANDS NOW AS WITH
ALL ALLOCATIONS IN THE BRANCH
THAT JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS AS IS
INFORMED THROUGH ITS COMMITTEES
AND THE TRIAL COURT LEADERSHIP.
ACTUALLY HAS A LARGE SET OF
COMMITTEES THAT WILL WORK UP
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN SUGGEST
TO IT NOT UNLIKE THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS HERE AND THEN MAKE AN
ALLOCATION SO. I IF I'M
EXPLAINING IT WELL ENOUGH IT
WILL BE THE COUNCIL BUT THAT
DECISION IS SO WELL INFORMED BY
A LOT OF PARTICIPATION ON THE
LOWER COMMITTEES IN TRIAL COURT
MEMBERSHIP. THAT IT'S ALMOST AS
IF THERE IS A DISTINCTION
WITHOUT A DIFFERENCE HOW MANY
PEOPLE ON THIS GALGIANI THERE
ARE TWENTY ONE VOTING MEMBERS.
ALONG WITH AN EIGHTY GIVE THE
TIME EIGHT TO NINE ADVISORY
MEMBERS.
I AND THEN THERE ARE SOME LOWER
COMMITTEES OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT A KEY COMMITTEES
WHAT WE CALL OUR TRIAL COURT
BUDGET ADVISORY COMMITTEE WELL
QUALIFIED TO BEAR ON THE
COUNCIL.
I IT'S COMPRISES A
CONSTITUTIONALLY CREATED BODY
AND SO IT IS CHAIRED BY IS IT
MADE OF WHAT IS THAT'S OUR AS IT
GVES YOU AS IF I HAD THE SENATE
CHIEF JUSTICE IS THE CHAIR OF
THE COUNCIL IT HAS SOME SUPREME
COURT A SUPREME COURT MEMBER.
AND THEN ALSO HAS SOME ASSOCIATE
COURTS OF APPEAL JUSTICES HAVE
CELL AND TRIAL COURT. JUDGES
THAT ARE PART OF IT IT HAS TWO
MEMBERS FROM THE LEGISLATURE ONE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. AND ONE FROM
THE SENATE AND THEN FOR MEMBERS
FROM THE STATE BAR.
OKAY THANK YOU IT'S VERY
HELPFUL.
OKAY MISSPELL.
THANK YOU THIS IS A I THINK A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT.
OUR ROLE AND TALK ABOUT THAT
THAT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND.
I AM ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF
ENSURING THAT WE'RE GETTING
EXTRA MONEY DOWN AND SPECIAL TO
THE TRIAL COURT'SBUT IT'S ALSO
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE COME
THROUGH. THE FUTURES COMMISSION
AND THINGS THAT ARE PRIORITIES
FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
TWO OF WHICH I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO PUT ON THIS COMMITTEES
RIGHT ARE MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT I WOULD.
ASK US TO CONSIDER THEM.
AND ONE OF WHICH IS TESTING A A
ONE COURT PILOT FOR COMBINING.
DODD JUVENILE COURTS TOGETHER IN
A LARGER SENSE THERE'S SOME
SMALL COUNTIES THAT HAVE COME BY
JUVENILE COURTS BUT.
IF WE COULD TAKE A LOOK AT
LARGER COUNTIES SANTA CLARA
ACTUALLY HAS BEEN WORKING ALONG.
THIS LINE BUT.
THIS WOULD THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN LOOKED AT BY THE BY
THE LEGISLATURE THE JUDICIAL.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HUMAN SERVICES HAD A
JOINT HEARING TO LOOK A
COMBINING THESE TWO.
AREAS WE TEND TO DO SO MUCH.
DECISIONS REALLY IN TWO VERY
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS THAT.
.
DUAL SYSTEM AND THAT DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM AND NICK IF WORKING WITH
THE COURTS IN THIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION COMMANDED FUTURES
COMMISSION.
WE GOT HOW WE DO A BETTER SYSTEM
FOR KIDS AT RISK THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT WOULD BE THAT
MUCH I DON'T HOW MUCH OF THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION BUT I THINK
IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT.
AND THEN THE OTHERS ALSO
FEATURES COMMISSION
RECOMMENDATION THAT COMES OUT OF
A PROJECT IT'S BEEN BEEN WORKING
IN IN FRESNO WHERE THERE ARE.
CHILD CUSTODY DECISIONS THAT
DON'T INVOLVE ABUSE.
AND THEY PROVIDED REAL MEDIATION
THAT IS MEDIATION WITHOUT MAKING
A RECOMMENDATION THAT THEN SUCH
INTERFERES WITH THE PARTIES
ABILITY TO TO COME TO A REAL
AGREEMENT. AGAIN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FUTURES COMMISSION I THINK
THAT'S ON THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY LOOK AT THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND IF WE CAN PRIORITIZE
AT LEAST THOSE TWO. AREAS WE
WOULD BE DOING A BETTER JOB
PROTECTING KIDS IN CALIFORNIA.
OKAY I WANT TO THANK YOU OFFER
THAT ONE OF THE CONCERNS I THINK
WE HAVE AS A COMMITTEE AND.
AND I'VE HAD A. NUMBER OF
PERSONS TO CALL IN EXPRESS A
CONCERN NOT NOT ABOUT THE
AMOUNTS THAT WE PUT OUT THERE
YOU KNOW UP AND SEVEN FIVE
MILLION IS OBVIOUSLY.
WARRANTED AND PROBABLY EVEN
MORE IN TERMS OF WHAT WHERE HOW
FAR WE NEED TO GO TO COURT. BUT
THE QUESTION BECOMES AS WE KEEP
ASKING WHAT ARE THE REAL
PRIORITIES THAT ARE GOING TO
DRIVE THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES.
YOU KNOW A WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
ISSUES HERE AND AND AT THIS AT
OUR LEVEL WITH REGARDS TO. THE
pNOT. WE DON'T KNOW IF IF YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF TIME ALONG IT TAKES A
PERSON TO GET THE COURT. OF
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT APPEAR BECAUSE WE
HEAR THAT A LOT FOR MY MEMBERS.
OF SOME OF THE INNOVATIVE THINGS
AS MRS STONE TALKED ABOUT WITH
THE CAR SUPPORT RESTRUCTURING
ORGANIZATION.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE
THINGS AND SO YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO LOOK AT THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE HAVE TO DO THAT AS WE. WE
LISTEN AND WE HEAR THAT.
THAT THERE THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN THE AND THE COURTS
THEMSELVES ARE ALL WALKING AND
TALKING PRETTY MUCH IN THE SAME
DIRECTION.
BUT YET I HEAR LITTLE
DISSIDENTS WHEN I HEAR THEM SAY
BUT WE WANT TO CONTROL WHAT WE
DO WITH THE MONEY. UP BECAUSE IT
TO IT IF THAT'S THE CASE AND WE
COULD PROBABLY A FIGURE OUT THE.
THE FORMULA AND ALLOCATED
DIRECTLY TO THE COURTS AND
BYPASS THE COUNCIL COMPLETELY
AND END UP GIVING IT TO THE
COURTS THEMSELVES. AND NOT DEAL
WITH THE COUNCIL IF IF IF
EVERYBODY'S WALKING AND TALKING
IN THE SAME DIRECTION MAYBE THEY
ARE MAYBE THEY ARE. BUT IF THE
MONEY IS ACTUALLY GOING TO GO
DOWN TO THE COURTS IN THE DUST
SO THEN THE DISCRETION BECOMES
THEIR DISCRETION. BUT I THINK
WE'VE LEARNED FROM.
PLEASE I'VE LEARNED FROM LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA FOR
SCHOOLS.
THAT WITHOUT CLEAR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND AND EXPECTATIONS
OF WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL LOOK
LIKE. YOU MAY NOT GET WHAT YOU
WANT IN THE END AND SO IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE BETTER
SIR.
OF THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA HOW SO
I THINK WE'VE ASKED A COUPLE
TIMES WHAT ARE THE PRIORITIES OF
OF THE OF THE OF THE OF THE OF
COURTS. WITH REGARDS TO.
TO GIVE SOME AT LEAST SOME
FRAMEWORK IN GUIDELINE AS TO HOW
THAT WOULD HAPPEN. A IF IT'S A
MATTER OF BOOK FORMULA WITH
REGARDS TO ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES CAN WE ACTUALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT.
COUNTIES OF QUARTZ I GUESS
HAVING.
AT LEAST WHAT THEY CONSIDER A
FAIR ALLOCATION BASED ON THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE IN THE
COURTS OF A HAT. SO I DON'T HAVE
A.
A SENSE OF THAT.
AT THIS TIME AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL AS WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE JUST GIVE THE
FIFTY TO SEVENTY FIVE. MILLION
IN ONE DIRECTION WHAT WE GIVE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION WITH A LIST
OF PRIORITIES FROM THIS FROM
THIS BODY. OF OR WHETHER WE
DECIDE THAT.
THIS IF WE'RE GONNA DO
DISCRETION AND EVERYBODY
BELIEVES THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
HAVE DISCRETION WHETHER THAT WE
ACTUALLY ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES
TO THE VARIOUS COURTS. OF THE
FIFTY COURTS AND ALLOW THEM TO
HAVE THE DISCRETION AS TO HOW
THEY WOULD MEET OUR EXPECTATIONS
WITH REGARD TO JUSTICE AND
SERVICE FOR THE PEOPLE.
OF CALIFORNIA SO THOSE OF THE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT'S
RUNNING THROUGH MY MIND THAT
I'VE KEEP LOOKING FOR AND HOPING
TO FIND. AND I SUMA FIND IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
A SEMI HELP ME FIND IN TERMS OF
THE PRIORITIES THAT ARE SET
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US AT THIS LEVEL
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE
BEGINNING TO CHIP AWAY AT THE
PROBLEMS AND CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT A WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE COURTS AND YOU KNOW NOT THAT
THEY'VE CREATED A PROBLEM WE
CREATED THEM WITH THE LACK OF
RESOURCES WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND.
AND WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
LISA MOVING IN THE DIRECTION
THAT WE WANT TO GO.
SO THAT TO THEIR SOME FAIRNESS
ACROSS THE BOARD NOT ONLY MONTH
WITH THE JUDGES EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT WHAT THE STAFFING IS AND
HOW. AND AND GIVE ME TO SOME THE
BACKLOG THAT I HEAR A LOT ABOUT
THE TERM STAFF THERE'S A LOT OF
BACKLOGS WHICH MEANS ME A LOT OF
FOLKS PROCESSING STUFF. A EARLY
ON IN AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
AND SO.
SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
PRIORITIES IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
ITEM AND YOU KNOW THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT BASED ON THE KIND
OF INFORMATION WE'VE HAD COMING
TO US.
AS LEGISLATORS.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO
ADD YES DOCTOR WEBER IF I COULD
AT LEAST LEAVE YOU.
AND YOUR MEMBERS WITH THIS
IMPRESSION THE LIST OF THINGS
THAT YOU JUST CITED. ARE THE
SAME THINGS THAT WE HEAR
THE SAME THING THAT EVERY
PRESIDING JUDGE IN THE SYSTEM
HERE'S AND SO AGAIN I THINK
THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF OVERLAP
ON HOW. OF THESE PRIORITIES WHO
CAN GET TEASED OUT AND AIRED OUT
I DO THINK WE CAN WORK WITH YOU
TO. ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR AN
ARTICLE IN THAT BLANK SO THAT
THIS BODY HAS.
YOU KNOW OF A REASONABLE STRONG
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE THAT THE
APPROPRIATION THAT IT MAKES WILL
BE ALLOCATED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
OUR COLLECTIVE PRIORITIES. GOING
FORWARD IT WILL ADDRESS MANY OF
THINGS THAT YOU JUST ARTICULATE
FOUNDER LESS AND I BELIEVE THAT
WILL HAPPEN I MEAN I I'VE TALKED
WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND AND.
WE SHARE SOME OF THE SAME
CONCERNS FOR FAMILY COURT AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON AND WE ALLOCATE
RESOURCES IN THE PAST BASED ON
THE CONVERSATION IS THERE. SO
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T AND OURSELVES YOU'RE
THINKING WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
WIN IT WITH SOMETHING ELSE AND
THEN WE HAVE FOLKS STILL WAITING
TO GET JUSTICE AND. AND WE
THOUGHT WELL WE SHOULD HAVE PUT
MORE OVER HERE VERSUS THERE BUT
I THINK THERE ARE SIMILARITIES
WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHILE TALKING THE SAME LANGUAGE.
OKAY DOT DOT ORG ON ME YEAH WERE
GIVEN THE PRIORITIES I AGREE
WITH MR SHINO. ON AS A PRESIDING
JUDGE WAS NOT MY HEAD WITH ALL
THOSE PRIORITIES AND I'M HERE
WITH CONFIDENCE THAT THERE WILL
BE A FAIR ALLOCATION NOT ONLY TO
MY CORPORATE ALL OTHER FIFTY
SEVEN COURTS. ALL THE PRESIDING
JUDGES ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS AND AND BELIEVE THE RIGHT
PRIORITIES WE MET IN THE RIGHT
ALLOCATION WILL BE DONE DON'T
GOOD SOUNDS GREAT THANK YOU ALL
BE HELD OPEN. WILL NOW MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO ISSUE TO THE
PILOT PROJECT WELL ONLINE
ADJUDICATION OF TRAFFIC
VIOLATIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS LOT
KOPITAR* ON THE BUDGET
DIRECTOR FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. AND I HAVE HERE WITH ME
IS THE DIRECTOR OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERVICES AYE SHELLEY
CURRAN WHO WILL WALK YOU THROUGH
THE ISSUE NUMBER TWO REGARDING
THE PILOT PROJECT FOR. ONLINE
ADJUDICATION OF TRAFFIC
VIOLATIONS VERY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AS LUCK ASSEMBLYMAN SHELLEY
CURRAN I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SERVICES FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
OF THE BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES A THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND.
ALLOCATION.
AND SEVEN POSITIONS FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND SEVEN
POSITIONS I'M GOING TO DESIGN
DEPLOY AND MAINTAIN SOFTWARE TO
ADJUDICATE A TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS
ON LINE AND DESIGNATED PILOT
COURTS.
IN APRIL OF LAST YEAR.
THIRD CHIEF JUSTICE RECEIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE FUTURES
COMMISSION.
WOULD SET FORTH LEGAL AND
STRUCTURAL CHANGES FOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COURT SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE. OF THE PUBLIC
GOING FORWARD ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE CHIEF
FAST UMP TO MOVE FORWARD ON
QUICKLY WAS.
RELATES TO CIVIL ADJUDICATION
OF TRAFFIC MATTERS.
AN ONLINE ADJUDICATION OF THESE
MATTERS ALSO. A WORK GROUP IS
MEETING REGULARLY AND TO DEVELOP
A FULL PROPOSAL.
WE WILL BE HAVING AYE A MEETING
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH
ACTUALLY WOBBLE WE WHERE WE WILL
BE RECEIVING. A PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND PUBLIC INPUT ON TO THAT
PROPOSAL. UP THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL IS REALLY A FIRST UP
ANNA IN MOVING TOWARDS A FUTURES
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS ON BY
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING FOR THE
ONLINE ADJUDICATION OF TRAFFIC
MATTERS.
AND BY FACILITATING TRIALS BY
WRITTEN DECLARATION WITHOUT THE
FULL DEPOSIT OF BAIL THAT IS
REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW RIGHT
NOW. AMID ALSO WITHOUT THE RIGHT
TO A TRIAL THE NOBLE.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL ALSO
FACILITATES I'M A PRICE OF
JUSTICE AWARD THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL RECEIVED ON OCTOBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN. FROM THE YOU'D
US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS IT IT
WILL ALLOW US TO REDUCE SOME
MANDATORY FINES AND FEES THAT
ARE UNDER IT IT VETERAN EXISTING
LAW. ON IT'LL PROVIDE FOR THE
ELECTRONIC VERIFICATIONS OF A
PERSON'S RECEIPT OF PUBLIC
BENEFITS WITH THE CONSUMER'S
CONSENT.
AND IT WILL AUTOMATE THE
ABILITY TO PAY.
.
SO WE WERE ONE OF FIVE OF FIVE
STATE COURT SYSTEMS THAT THAT
RECEIVE THAT THAT OUR AWARD
NATIONALLY. AND FIVE PILOT FIVE
COURTS HAVE STEPPED UP ANNA AND
AGREED TO SERVE AS PILOTS.
IN THIS IN THIS OP PROJECT
TULARE JUST US IN FRANCISCO
VENTURA AND SANTA CLARA.
OTHER COUNCIL HAS SELECTED A
BITTER THROUGH COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS TO DEVELOP A
TOOL.
TO FOR THE ONLINE EDUCATION UP
PARDON ME FOR THE ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATION AND.
IS WE ARE IN THE PROCESS NOW OF
DEVELOPING THAT WILL WITH THEM.
WORKING WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
TO CREATE A LINK FOR A CONSUMER
TO OPT INTO TO CONFIRM RECEIPT
OF.
.
PUBLIC BENEFITS.
AND THERE WERE ALSO PROVIDING
INPUT ON INFORMATION FROM
DEFENDANTS ON WHO ARE NOT PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE RECIPIENTS.
OF THE THE PILOTS AND THE VENDOR
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TO DATE A COURTS ARE FINALIZING
THE DATA THAT WILL BE USED TO
DETERMINE INDIGENTS. AND THE
DATA USED BY THE SYSTEM TO TO
GENERATE A REDUCTION
RECOMMENDATION THAT WILL GO
BEFORE THE JUDGE.
FOR EXAM THEY'RE THEY'RE ALSO
MAKING DETERMINATIONS RIGHT NOW
ABOUT WHAT THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL BE AND FOR EXAMPLE.
OUR PILOTS NOW HAVE HAVE
DETERMINED THAT THEY WILL REDUCE
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE RECIPIENTS
BETWEEN FIFTY AND EIGHTY PERCENT
OF A OF A TRAFFIC FINER FEE.
THE FUNDING FOR THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF WILL ALLOW US TO BRING ON
THREE ADDITIONAL PILOTS IT'LL
PROVIDE FOR THE SEVEN JUDICIAL
COUNCIL STAFF THAT THAT WE.
EXPECT WILL TAKE OVER THE.
THE TOOL ONCE A TOOL HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED.
AND IT WILL ALLOW US TO
IMPLEMENT CHAT BUT A LOT OF
FUNCTIONALITY FOR CONSUMERS AS
THEY ARE ADJUDICATING THESE
MATTERS ONLINE. AND IT WILL ALSO
ALLOW US TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION OF THE
PROJECT AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THAT EVALUATION WILL WILL
INCLUDE.
WHAT DETERMINATIONS WERE MADE
WHAT THE IMPACT WAS?
DEMOGRAPHICS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
USING THE TOOL SELECTION HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF WHO IS USING THE
TOOL. I'M AND WHAT THE IMPACT IS
GENERALLY ON CONSUMERS.
IN A NUTSHELL THE PRICE OF THE
WAY THAT WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
THIS IS THE PRICE OF JUSTICE
GRANT COM. I THE PROOF PROOF OF
CONCEPT.
THIS BCP IS THE PRODUCTION
PILOT HOME WITH ONGOING SUPPORT.
IT WILL ALLOW US TO DO THAT GAP
ANALYSIS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
PROBLEMS THERE MIGHT BE SO WE
CAN RESOLVE THEM BEFORE I AM.
THE PROJECT GOES STATEWIDE
BECAUSE WE IT IT IS OUR HOPE
THAT THAT THE PROJECT WILL GO
STATEWIDE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
FINANCE.
YES WE BELIEVE THIS PROTEST
PILOT PROGRAM WILL HELP
EXPLORATORIUM OPTION WHICH WILL
BE CONVENIENT NOT ONLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS UTILIZING THE COURT
SYSTEM BUT ALSO FOR THE COURTS
THEMSELVES. IN THE HIGHEST
FREQUENCY TYPE OF CASE.
IN ADDITION IT BUILDS AND
EXPANDS UPON MANY OF THE EFFORTS
WHICH MAKES MISS CURRENT TOUCHED
UPON THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AUTHORITY UNDERTAKEN. FOR
EXPLORING BETTER MEANS OF
DETERMINING AN INDIVIDUAL'S
ABILITY TO PAY TO PAY THEIR
FINES AND FEES.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT COMMITTEE
STAFF THE OHIO AND STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE SHARED A LOT OF THOUGHTFUL
INPUT FROM THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THIS ITEM. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT PUBLIC WORKS
OKAY. ANY COMMENTS LA JOH.
AS NOTED THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES A THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ARE OFTEN
AUGMENTATION TWO MILLION OF THAT
IS ONE TIME AND ONE POINT FOUR
IS ONGOING. WE DO RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE REQUEST BUT FOR
THE ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ONLY PROVIDING THAT ON A
FOUR YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS.
THE REASON FOR THAT IS WE FIND
THAT IT IS PREMATURE TO PROVIDE
ONGOING RESOURCES BEFORE A PILOT
IS COMPLETE AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS
WHETHER IT SHOULD BE CONTINUED.
ON INTO THE FUTURE.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OR MODIFY THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IN AT LEAST TWO WAYS TO ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. RECEIVES
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION TO
EVALUATE THE PILOT.
THE FIRST AS MENTIONS ON
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT COURTS ARE
ESTIMATED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PILOT. WE RECOMMEND REQUIRING
THAT EACH OF THE PROPOSED
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE IN THE PILOT
BE TESTED AT A MINIMUM OF THREE
QUARTS.
RATHER THAN ALLOWING THE PILOT
COURTS TO CHOOSE WHICH
ACTIVITIES THEY WANT TO TEST
BECAUSE THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT
EACH OF THE ACTIVITIES ARE
TESTED IN A COURT AND THEY'RE
TESTED AT COURTS WITH DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS PROPHECIES AND COURT
USERS.
SECOND WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL BE REQUIRED TO
EVALUATE THE PROPOSED PILOT AND
PROVIDE A REPORT BY DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WELL THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY DOES REQUIRE A REPORT
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PILOT THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT FOR
AN EVALUATION AND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT TO SUBMIT ANY TYPE
OF SPECIFIC TYPE OF INFORMATION.
AND SO WITHOUT IN OF VALUATION
THAT COMPLETELY CLEARLY COMPARES
THE PILOT SYSTEM TO THE EXISTING
SYSTEM IT WILL LIKELY BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
FULLY ASSESS THE PILOT AND
DETERMINE WHAT COMPONENTS IF
ANY.
SHOULD BE CONTINUED EXPANDED OR
MODIFIED.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER. COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE IN ONE IN FAVOR OF THE
PROPOSAL.
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE IN FAVOR OF IT.
MADAM CHAIR HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MAGGIE
SCHALLER AND I'M WITH THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA.
AS A PART OF OUR ADVOCACY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR YEARS TO REDUCE
THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF HIGH
COST TRAFFIC TICKETS ON LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST TRAFFIC FINES AND
FEES IN THE COUNTRY AND MORE
THAN FORTY PERCENT OF AMERICANS
CANNOT FORD AFFORD AN UNEXPECTED
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR EXPENSE.
WHICH IS THE COST OF ONE RED
LIGHT TICKET IN CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCILS.
ATTENTION TO THIS AND
COMMITMENT TO SOLVING THE
DILEMMA HOWEVER IT'S FIVE COUNTY
PILOT PROPOSAL IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TO FIX THE PROBLEM. FIRST
IT WOULD ONLY COVER.
FIVE AND POSSIBLY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE FIVE COUNTIES.
THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN WORKING
TO REDUCE TRAFFIC FINES AND FEES
FOR SIX YEARS AND CALIFORNIA'S
PREVIOUSLY DONE A STATEWIDE
AMNESTY PROGRAM. TO RETURN WITH
WITH A FIVE COUNTY PIE THAT
WOULD BE A STEP BACKWARD I'M
SECOND THE PILOT PROVIDES NO
STANDARDS FOR FINES AND FEES
REDUCTIONS IT'S THE
LEGISLATURE'S JOB TO SET FAIR
FINES AND FEES IN THIS PILOT
WOULD GIVE. TOTAL DISCRETION TO
THE COURTS TO SET THE FINES WITH
NO GUIDELINES TO CREATE. A
EQUITY AND FINES AND FEES ACROSS
COUNTIES WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REDUCE EXISTING AND
FUTURE TRAFFIC THAT BY EIGHTY
PERCENT FOR ALL LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. WITH THINK WITH
MONTHLY PAYMENT PLANS WITH
PAYMENTS NO MORE THAN FIVE
PERCENT OF A PERSON'S INCOME.
AND REQUIRING COURTS TO RICK TO
REINSTATE SUSPENDED LICENSE ONCE
A PERSON MAKES A COURT
APPEARANCE.
FINALLY WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE OFTEN A
LIFE CHANGING ONE FOR MANY MOST
IN NEED.
AND CREATING A STATEWIDE
STANDARD WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU I ASSUME THAT'S IT IN
FAVOR STATEMENT OR NOT. OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BERNIE STONECIPHER AND WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED THERE'S
BEEN ANOTHER NUMBER FOR FORUMS
ON THIS ISSUE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. WE HAD AN AMNESTY PROGRAM
A FEW YEARS AGO AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENS THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHOSE
LICENSES WERE SUSPENDED FOR AN
ABILITY TO PAY TICKETS AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS MORE WHO
JUST COULDN'T AFFORD TO PAY
HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN TICKETS. SO WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF BEING ABLE
TO MAKE.
EDUCATIONS IN TRAFFIC COURT
MORE CONVENIENT BY MOVING THEM
ONLINE BUT WE'RE CONCERNS THAT
HAVING JUST A PILOT PROGRAM WITH
THE EXISTING LANGUAGE WOULD STOP
PROGRESS OVERTHE NEXT THREE
YEARS FLASHY RESIGN AND TO
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS FOR FAILURES
TO PAY BUT THERE ARE STILL. MANY
MANY THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY THESE
TICKETS AND IN PARTICULAR MY
ORGANIZATION IS CONCERNED WITH
PEOPLE COMING HOME FROM JAIL OR
PRISON. WHO RD SUFFER FROM HIGH
RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT INTENT THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
CLINIC?
SEVENTY PERCENT OF PEOPLE COME
TO THAT CLINIC ARE UNEMPLOYED
AND THOSE WHO HAD ONLY MET YES.
SO WE WOULD WANT TO SEE IDEALLY
THIS LANGUAGE INCLUDES STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR EIGHTY PERCENT
REDUCTION FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
INDIGENT CD DON'T HAVE THIS
VARIATION ACROSS COURTS IN
BETWEEN.
JUDGES IN A SINGLE COUNTY.
AND IF ONLY IN THE PILOT
PROGRAM WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE ALL
THE PARTICIPATING PILOTS INCLUDE
THE SPECIFIC REDUCTIONS FOR.
EIGHTY PERCENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE AN AGENT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS WAY TO ASK YOU ON THE
MANAGING ATTORNEY LEGAL SERVICES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. LIKE TO
REITERATE IN A FIRM WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AT LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRESENTS FOR CHILDREN LEADERS.
ARE IN THE LEGAL COMMITTEE JUST
SUBMITTED A WHILE GENERALLY WE
ARE IN FAVOR OF MAKING COURT
THROUGH AN ONLINE EDUCATION
PROCESS OR OTHERWISE MORE
CONVENIENT FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS.
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
FOR ANY TRAFFIC COURT RELATED
LEGISLATION INCLUDING THIS
ONLINE A PROPOSAL TO CLARIFY THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE HOLD FOR
FAILURE TO APPEAR. BE LIFTED
IMMEDIATELY AFTER A PERSON MAKE
AN APPEARANCE IN COURT BY.
ANY NUMBER OF MEANS AND CLARIFY
WHAT DOES MEANS OF APPEARANCE
ARE.
SO OUR OFFICES.
BOTH HEARD REPORTS AND SEEN
FIRST HAND
THAT SOME COURTS INCLUDING
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SISKIYOU
COUNTY. HAVE REYES BARRIERS TO
INDIVIDUALS CLEARING A FAILURE
TO APPEAR HOLD ON A DRIVERS
LICENSE JUST APPEARING IS NOT
ENOUGH FOR EXAMPLE. ONE SOME UP
ABSOLUTE HAVE A MINUTE.
OKAY.
SO. WHAT WE WOULD?
WHY PRO WOULD REQUEST IS AS PART
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM OR ANY
RELATED LEGISLATION THAT AN
APPEARANCE BY ANY MEANS WHETHER
IT'S A ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATION SUBMITTED ONLINE?
WHETHER IT'S A WRITTEN
DECLARATION COUNTIES IN
APPEARANCE AND THAT DRIVERS
LICENSE WILL BE LIFTED AT THAT
BE CLARIFIED AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY ANGER ON LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
I AND MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES. AND WANNA HIGHLIGHT
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO PILOT THE
IDEA THAT REDUCTIONS IN FEES AND
FINES HELP GET LOW INCOME
DRIVERS BACK ON THEIR FEET WE
SAW THAT ANNA SEES. IT PERCENT
REDUCTION GOT TO INNER THOUSAND
PEOPLE BACK ON THE ROAD ASTHMA
IN THE PILOT PROJECT DOES NOT
ENSURE THAT ABILITY TO PAY WILL
BE INCLUDED FOR EVERY COURT
PILOT IN NET. AND WHILE IT MIGHT
CREATE A STANDARDIZED PROCESS IT
DOESN'T CREATE A STANDARDIZED
INCOME FOR LOW INCOME DEFENDANTS
IN THE COURTS THAT ARE PILING IT
OR THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LOW
INCOME DRIVERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND NEED RELIEF FROM
THE HIGH COST OF TICKETS NOW AND
THOSE REDUCTIONS SHOULD BE
UNIVERSAL. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THANK THANK YOU.
HELLO I JEAN AND OLIVER SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE APPRECIATE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCILS EFFORT TO DESIGN A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT IMPROVES
ACCESS AND FAIRNESS OF THE
COUNTY A TRAFFIC COURT BY
OFFERING ONLINE I'D TRAFFIC CASE
OPTIONS INCLUDING ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATION. THE RECOGNITION
THAT THE SYSTEM WE HAVE NOW
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE ONE THE
OBJECTIVES OF FISCAL STABILITY
FOR THE BRANCH INTO. FEES AND
FINES AT SERVICE DETRIMENT AND
FAIRLY PUNISHING LAWBREAKERS
WITHOUT PUSHING PEOPLE INTO
POVERTY OR WORSE JAIL IS A
COURAGEOUS ONE. NEVERTHELESS WE
BELIEVE ONE THAT THE PILOT DOES
NOT ESTABLISH AN ABILITY TO PAY
STANDARD.
WHICH IS AIMED.
WITH THE AID IS NOT A STANDARD
IT'S IT'S.
BE AT JUST THE PILOT PROGRAM TO
IT WILL TAKE MORE THAN THREE
YEARS TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT
IMPACT AND BY THEN MANY MANY
MORE PEOPLE WILL BE DRIVEN INTO
POVERTY WITHOUT THE SYSTEM. THE
LACK OF A STANDARD SPECIFICALLY
CONCERNING TO US NOT ONLY A
STANDARD OF HOW TO CALCULATE IT
BUT ALSO HOW TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
IT. AND LET ME TELL YOU WHY
SOMEONE UP SUMMING UP.
SO.
A YEAR AGO WILL BE COMMISSIONED
A REPORT BY LAWYERS COMMITTEE
FOR CIVIL RIGHT THAT WAS
REFERENCE BEFORE THE NINE
COUNTIES IN THE BAY AREA THAT.
SHOULD HAVE HAD AN ABILITY TO
PAY DETERMINATION I HAD NONE IN
THEIR WEBSITE ONLINE OR IN
PERSON.
SO IF WE HAD DON'T HAVE A
STANDARD BOTH FOR ACCESS IS WAYS
TO CALCULATE IT I'M THE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE PEOPLE COLOR WILL
BE.
MOST ARE IMPACTED BY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WENT BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
SUPPORT EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE
HOWEVER THIS PROPOSAL HAS
CERTAIN CONCERNS VERTICALLY WITH
OUR. COMMUNITY THAT SPEAKS A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AND THEN ALSO HOW TO ADDRESS ANY
RECOMMENDATION THAT SHOULD BE
BROUGHT FORWARD FOR THEM TO
ACCESS A PILOT SUCH AS THIS BUT
I ALSO ECHO OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE.
OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OUR
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED ARE FROM
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
CRITICALLY IN RURAL AREAS SO IS
THERE STILL CONCERNS TO BE.
HAD HERE AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
BE BROUGHT FORWARD THANK YOU.
I MADAM CHAIR MICRO WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY A WE
WE STAND.
IN CAN IN AGREEMENT WITH THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS IN THE OUTLINE OF THE
ISSUES I AM I I WOULD JUST NOTE
TO THE COMMITTEE. ON THIS IS A
SIX YEAR OLD ISSUE WE'VE MADE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR IN
PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN GREAT THE
COURTS HAVE WORKED HAND IN HAND
WITH US FOR MANY YEARS. ALL LAST
YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO PASS A BILL
AB FIVE WITH THREE BY SIMPLY
MEMBER LACKEY THE CREATED
SIMILAR STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR
PARKING TICKETS WE DO NOT THINK
IT'S A BIG STEP TO DO THE SAME
TO HAVE ACROSS THE BOARD YOU
OCCASIONS. OF THESE TICKETS FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND GIVING
THOSE DISCOUNTS.
I WANT TO KNOW WE DO SUPPORT
ONLINE EDUCATION WE DO THINK
IT'S THE WAVE OF THE FUTURE WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON THESE
MATTERS AND LOOK FOR TO KEEP
DOING SO. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO HAVE GOOD
AFTERNOON KEVIN AS THEIR
QUARTERS CALIFORNIA FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS WITH SUPPORT OF
THE POP OF THE PROPOSAL. AN
ONLINE A COMMON THROUGH PREVIOUS
COMMENTS OF THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAUREN
CLIMB WITH THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO REITERATE THE
COMMENTS OF MY LEGAL AID
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY AND
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS IN THE DAIS.
REMEMBER COUNTLESS ROOM BOOKLET
JUST SOME CLARIFICATION I. I CAN
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE  WANTED
TO MAKE SURE PROGRAM WORKS
FULLY.
.
BEFORE FUNDING ACROSS THE STRAIT
BUT.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE DO HAVE QUITE A
BIT OF DATA ALREADY. WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE THE THE BENEFIT FOR
EXTENDING THIS?
?
THIS ANALYSIS.
I'M SORRY SOMEONE THOUGH RIGHT
WITH THE ANALYSIS.
YES I DO THE PROPOSED.
PILOT PROGRAM.
WELL WHAT WHAT THE PARENT WILL
ALLOW US TO DO IS IS IT WILL
ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR THE ONLINE
ADJUDICATION OF TRAFFIC MATTERS.
AND SO.
AND THEN IT WILL WILL ADDRESS
BOTH TRIAL BY WRITTEN
DECLARATION AND TRIAL DE NOVO
AND SO WHAT WE WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE DOING AND THEN
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ABILITY TO
PAY CONCERNS AT THAT HAVE BEEN.
THE TOPIC OF OF MANY OF THE
COMMENTS AND SO WHAT WHAT THIS
WHAT WHAT WE ANTICIPATE DOING
IS.
GATHERING DATA.
FROM THE TOOL ACTUALLY WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE VENDOR TO
DESIGN THE TOOL SO THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO EXTRACT DATA.
AND THEN WE WILL PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION.
TO WE HAVE TO PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION TO THE U. S. DOJ AS
PART OF THE GRANT THAT WE
RECEIVED AND THEN ALSO TO
LEGISLATURE. OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
NO COMMENTS.
OKAY I THINK VIA AUDIENCES HAS
RAISED SOME VERY IMPORTANT
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS AND SO.
I THINK THERE'S SOME
INFORMATION HERE WITH REGARDS TO
MAKING SURE THAT.
LEAST THESE.
THE SOFTWARE AND AND THE OF
THAT.
WILL BASICALLY HAVE THOSE OTHER
ELEMENTS IN IT THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO IDENTIFY THOSE WHO CAN AND
CANNOT PAY I THINK THAT'S THE
MAIN CONCERN. MUCH OF EVERYONE
BEEN NOT OPPOSED TO ONLINE IN
AND HAVING ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
BUT THE QUESTION IS CAN ASK ALL
THE QUESTIONS AND MAKE THE
DETERMINATION THAT WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT. US SO THAT WE DON'T
FURTHER SEND PEOPLE INTO.
AND DEBT AND DIFFICULTY OH BY
HAVING SOMEONE THAT'S KIND OF
VERY SO GENERIC THAT AGO DID IT
MEET MEETS THE NEEDS OF.
SUPPOSED EVERYONE AND NO ONE AT
THE SAME TIME SO I. WILL LOOK AT
THAT AND SO I I THINK IT IS
POINTED OUT ALSO IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE.
THAT WE DO COME BACK AND ASSESS
WHAT THE NOT WE WANT TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE WE DO OFTEN PILOT
THINGS.
THE RIVER PILOT IS THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A TRIAL AARON TO
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON AND THEN
MAKE A DECISION WHETHER NOT YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE.
MANY TIMES WITH WE USE THE TERM
PILOT WHEN WE JUST WAS ABLE TO
REALLY SAY WILL START THIS
LIFELONG ACTIVITY SO.
I'M I'M HOPING THAT.
.
THAT WILL TAKETHAT INTO
CONSIDERATION SERIOUSLY THAT IS
A PILOT SO WE CAN MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF IT. OF BEFORE WE
FIND OURSELVES OVERWHELMED WITH
IT AND THEN ONCE AGAIN LOOKING
FOR ANOTHER PILOT THINK IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD NOT AYE
ISSUE NUMBER THAT ITEM TO WILL
BE HELD OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS A
SELF HELP CENTER.
TOM.
THANK YOU OKAY.
OF GOOD AFTERNOON I'M BUNNY HOP
FAN I'M A MANAGING ATTORNEY WITH
A JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
AND WORK ON SELF HELP PROGRAMS.
AND THIS IS.
A REQUEST FOR EXPANSION OF SELF
HELP CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ALREADY HAVE A CENTERS IN
EVERY COUNTY AND WITH ELEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS ARE
OVER ABLE TO SERVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE A YEAR IT'S JUST. AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF SERVICE
THAT'S PROVIDED.
GENERALLY THAT PROGRAMS ARE IN
FAMILY LAW WHICH AREA OF HUGE
NEED.
BUT WE KNOW THAT FOR EXAMPLE A
NEW EVERY DAY THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT CANNOT BE SERVED IN THE
SELF HELP CENTERS JUST WITH.
CURRENT FUNDING AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IN AREAS LIKE CLAMOR
TENANT.
CONSERVATORSHIP GUARDIANSHIP.
AND CONSUMER PROBLEMS MANY MANY
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO TO COURT
WITHOUT THE ASSISTANCE OF AN
ATTORNEY SELF HELP CENTERS
PEOPLE HELP PEOPLE FILL OUT
FORMS EXPLAINED THE PROCESS.
HELP THEM ENFORCE THEIR ORDERS
ONCE.
THE JUDGE MAKES AN ORDER OR
HELP THEM COMPLY DEPENDING ON
THE SITUATION. AND JUST MAKES
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM MOVE MORE
SMOOTHLY BUT MOST CRITICALLY IT
GIVES PEOPLE ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
THEY COURTS HAVE INDICATED A
NEED FOR AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ARE SIXTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THE SO THAT SIDE NINETEEN
POINT ONE MILLION WILL BE A HUGE
HELP OF. A IN IN ADDRESSING
THOSE NEEDS AND.
WE ANTICIPATE OF EXPANDING ALSO
IN AND NOW.
BY USING MORE COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY IN ASSISTANCE BUT THE
REALITY IS A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
JUST NEED SOMEBODY TO TALK TO.
AND THEY NEED SOMEBODY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESS AND TO HOLD
THEIR HAND AND HONESTLY ISSUES
ARE AWFULLY COMPLICATED AND.
OFTEN HARD TO DEAL WITH WITH
COMPUTER PROGRAMS
SO THOSE ARE GROUP THAT'S A
GREAT SUPPLEMENT IS ABLE TO
SERVE A LOT OF PEOPLE. BUT.
THE COURTS REALLY NEED THAT IN
PERSON STAFFING TO PROVIDE THIS
ASSISTANCE OKAY ANY COMMENTS
FROM FINANCE.
YES REBEKAH KIRK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WANT TO REITERATE THE
NEED FOR THIS PROPOSAL. AND A
WHITE JUSTIFIES AND ONGOING
INVESTMENT AS WE HEARD FROM MR
SHINO EARLIER ON THIS IS SELF
HELP IS THE FASTEST GROWING
PUBLIC NEED FACING THE COURT
SYSTEM. WITH NINETY PERCENT OF
WHAT AGAINST A FAMILY LAW M.
ARRIVING TO COURT WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION NINETY PERCENT OF
TENANTS AND EVICTION CASES. AND
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF CIVIL
CASES AT LEAST ONE PARTY DOES
NOT HAVE REPRESENTATION. WE'VE
ALSO HEARD IN LARGE OR URBAN
COURTS FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
THAT THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME IS AN
HOUR AND A HALF FOR PARTS ONLY
SEVEN MINUTES OF INITIAL TRIAGE
TIME FROM THE SELF HELP CENTER.
THIS ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT WILL
HELP THE COURTS TO SERVE OVER
ONE MILLION ADDITIONAL SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS STATEWIDE.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE IS
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE INCLUDED
THAT THE FULL AMOUNT. BOTH THE
CONTINUING INVESTMENT AND THIS
NEW NINETEEN POINT ONE PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROCUREMENT OF THIRTY POINT
THREE MILLION. THE NEW BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE WILL ASSURE THAT
THIS MONEY IS ALL SPENT FOR.
SOME ASSISTANCE IN THE SELF HELP
CENTERS IN THE COURTS AND IF IT
IS NOT IT WILL REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. OKAY ANY COMMENTS
FROM ILLEGAL.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS.
OF THE SELF HELP SERVICES BY
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY.
A LIMITED SCOPE ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE DOES SUGGEST THAT THESE
SERVICES CAN PROVIDE STATE
BENEFIT WHILE INCREASING ACCESS
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
A RIGOROUS ANALYSIS WOULD HELP
THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE WHAT
THE TOTAL LEVEL OF NEED IS WHERE
FUNDING SHOULD BE TARGETED TO
MAXIMIZE BOTH STATE AND PUBLIC
BENEFIT. AND WHETHER FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED
ELSEWHERE TO ACCOUNT FOR ANY
SAVINGS.
UNTIL THE ANALYSIS IS COMPLETE
WE DO THINK IT IS REASONABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHEN
THAT ANALYSIS WOULD BE COMPLETE.
AS THE COURTS REPORT TURNING
AWAY INDIVIDUALS WERE SEEKING
ASSISTANCE.
THE EXACT AMOUNT TO PROVIDE
WOULD DEPEND ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES FOR
GENERAL FUND SPENDING SELF HELP
SERVICES ARE OTHER PART
PROGRAMS.
TO FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
OF ME WANTS TO TARGET FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
SERVICE IS PROVIDED IN CERTAIN
ISSUE AREAS ACROSS ALL TRIAL
COURTS.
OR THAT A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
FUNDING IS FUNDED A STATEWIDE
LEVEL ON PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT CAN BE DEPLOYED STATEWIDE
TO ASSIST MORE INDIVIDUALS.
I'M IN REGARDS TO THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE WE ARE
RECOMMENDING APPROVAL AS IT DOES
INCREASE THE ACCOUNTABLE USE OF
THESE DOLLARS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
ANY QUESTIONS HERE FOR MEMBERS
STONE.
JUST HEARD LIKE THE WAY IN AND
SAY THAT I THINK THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT PRIORITY THOUGH THAT
WE SHOULD THE FUNDING I
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
RECOGNIZED THE ONGOING NEED.
AND IT IS IN THE MONEY.
WILLING TO TO PUT INTO THIS YEAR
WE'VE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE HAVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
BY SOME THE COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHO NEED IT
THE MOST AND WE ARE MOVING MORE
AND MORE UNFORTUNATELY TO SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS AND THE
SELF HELP CENTERS ARE A
SIGNIFICANT. PART OF THEIR
ABILITY TO GET ACCESS TO
JUSTICE.
OKAY ANYONE.
YET A COMMON YES I'M SO IN A
COUPLE WITH A LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE INSTANCE SUPPORT OF THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR SELF HELP
CENTERS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY FUN I THINK MOST OF THE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED AND
I'VE.
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING MOST
OF US IN FAVOR OF SELF HELP
CENTERS. WITH SOME.
OBVIOUSLY LIMITATIONS BUT THERE
BUT CLEARLY THERE'S AN ADVANTAGE
TO IT WILL MAKE SURE WE'RE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT TAKES US TO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. OF SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS SERVICES
SUPPORT WEB PORTAL.
WE'LL BE HAVING STAFF COMING UP
AND THEY'RE GIVING A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
HAVE TO DEMAND CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARK LATE AND I AM THE
SUPERVISOR OF THE JC IT
WEBSERVICES TEAM.
AND I'M GONNA PROVIDERS THE HIGH
LEVEL DESCRIPTION OF THIS.
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS SRL
E. SERVICES PORTAL.
THE GOVERNOR'S UPDATED APRIL
BUDGET PROPOSED THREE POINT TWO
MILLION AND FOUR POSITIONS FOR
SELF WRITTEN THAT AT SUPPER
PRISON LITIGANTS ON PORTAL. TO
BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF
LITIGANTS WHO ARE SEEKING TO
RESEARCH IN FILE NON CRIMINAL
CASES WITHOUT THE EXPENSE OF
LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
AND.
.
IT IS VERY GERMANE TO OUR
SOCIETY TODAY WHEN MOST EVERY
GOVERNMENT AGENCY ON THE PLANET
IS TRYING TO TRANSFORM
BUSINESSES THAT TO BECOME A
DIGITAL SERVICE.
SO THINK OF THIS AS A DIGITAL
SERVICE CHANGING PARADIGM.
WE ARE.
BASICALLY TRYING TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
EXPECTATIONS ARE NO LESS STATE
CONDUCT BUSINESS WITH AMAZON
ONLINE DMV ONLINE AIRLINES AND
THEIR BANKS.
AND.
WE HOPE TO MAKE THAT THE SAME
WITH THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SO ONE OF THE GOALS IN THE
CURRENT JUDICIAL BRANCH STERN.
PLAN OF FOR TECHNOLOGY IS TO
CREATE DIGITAL COURT. AND YOU'LL
HEAR THAT TERM WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF OUR OUR DOCUMENTATION ON
OUR STRATEGIC PLAN. AND
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS DELIVER MORE SERVICES
ONLINE AND STOP PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM MAKING UNNECESSARY TRIPS TO
THE COURTS.
THE REQUESTED FUNDING
AUGMENTATION WILL ENABLE US TO
DESIGN BUILD AND DELIVER A
STATEWIDE E. SERVICES PORTAL.
SERVE THE GROWING NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ATTEMPTING
TO RESOLVE IN FILE LEGAL ISSUES
OUT WITHOUT THE COST OF AN
ATTORNEY.
THE.
THE THE INFANT THE ENVISIONED
PROGRAM IS AN END TO END
CUSTOMER JOURNEY FOR FOR
LITIGANTS.
BILL GUIDE WE WILL GUIDE PEOPLE
THROUGH THE PROCESS BEGINNING
WITH AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTRUCTIONAL COMPONENT WE WILL
SUPPLEMENT THAT WITH DOCUMENT
ASSEMBLY ALLOWING THEM TO FILL
DOCUMENTS OUT. WITH FORM
BUILDERS AND EVENTUALLY TO EFILE
AND YOU SUBMIT THEIR THEIR THEIR
CASE FILES ONLINE.
THE PORTAL WILL BE ADA
ACCESSIBLE IT WILL BE MOBILE
FRIENDLY AND IT WILL BE MULTI
LINGUAL.
TODAY CALIFORNIANS MUST GET IN
THEIR CARS.
DRIVE TO THE COURTHOUSE LOOK FOR
A PARKING SPOT WAIT MINE.
OFTEN DEFINE THAT THEY'VE COME
TO COURT WITHOUT THE RIGHT FORM
OR THEY'VE GOT THE RIGHT FORM IS
FILLED OUT INCORRECTLY. THAT E.
SERVICES PORTAL WILL AIM TO
CHANGE THAT PARADIGM AND
DELIVER.
I'M REALLY CUSTOMER SERVICE AND.
ACCESS TO PEOPLE WHO REALLY AND
A LIFE CRISIS ONE VIABLE
SITUATIONS ARM TO BASICALLY FILL
OUT AND FOLLOW THE PROCEDURES
CORRECTLY.
SO THE REQUESTED AUGMENTATION
REALLY IS IT'S
AS ON FOUR PILLARS THE FIRST OF
WHICH IS ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE ENTERPRISE WEB CONTENT
MANAGEMENT PLATFORM.
AND THIS WILL ENABLE US TO
DELIVER THE SERVICES THAT WE
WILL ACTUALLY BUILT TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC.
I'M ARE SECONDLY WE WILL INVEST
AND A LAYER OF INTERACTIVE
EDUCATIONAL ON INSTRUCTIONAL
INFORMATION.
I GUIDED INTERVIEWS.
.
VIDEO TUTORIALS
GLOSSARIES ONLINE GLOSSARIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN PEOPLE
ARE.
ATTEMPT TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
THEY'RE GETTING THE RIGHT
INFORMATION THEY NEED.
WE HEARD SOMEONE ADMITS IN CHAT
BOX WE ALSO ANDERSON CHAT BOX
TECHNOLOGY TO ALLOW FOLKS TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ONLINE TO GET
ANSWERS TO GET LINKS TO OTHER
RESOURCES. THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN
ANSWER THIRTY NINE MILLION PHONE
CALLS OR EVEN WANT TO ONE EMAILS
SO WE'RE GOING TO LEVERAGE THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
ANTICIPATING.
USER QUESTIONS AND NEEDS.
AND FINALLY WE WILL.
TOGETHER TECHNOLOGISTS AND
DEVELOPERS AND WE WILL DEVELOP
AN INTEGRATED SOLUTION THAT GOES
FROM THE BEGINNING OF A PROCESS
TO LEARN HOW TO DO SOMETHING ALL
THE WAY TO FILING A CASE.
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
BUT WHICH WE'RE GONNA START
DOING IT INCREMENTALLY BIT BY
BIT.
THANK YOU. YOU COME AS FINANCE.
HE HAS JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT
THIS ITEM REALLY COMPLIMENTS THE
LAST ITEM THAT WE DISCUSSED THE
NINETEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN SELF HELP
CENTERS. WITH THE DIFFERENCE
BEING THAT THAT NINETEEN POINT
ONE MILLION INVESTMENT IN SELF
HELP CENTERS ACTUALLY GOES TO
LOCAL ASSISTANCE WITHIN THOSE
SELF HELP CENTERS IN EACH TRIAL
COURT. AND THIS INVESTMENT WOULD
CREATE.
AS WE JUST HEARD THE PORTAL FOR
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO USE THE
INFORMATION ONLINE. AND WE SEE
THOSE OF COMPLEMENTARY AND ALSO.
THIS PORTAL WILL ALLOW SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS TO ADDRESS
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD ISSUES
THROUGH THE ONLINE SYSTEM IN NOT
INTO AND ENVIRONMENT AND.
ALSO WILL FREE UP RESOURCES
THAT THE SELF HELP CENTERS FOR
THOSE THAT ACTUALLY NEED IN
PERSON ASSISTANCE AND CURRENT.
INCOME AS WELL.
WE HAVE NOT COMPLETED OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE PROPOSAL AT THIS
TIME AND ARE RECOMMENDING
HOLDING IT OPEN SO FOR EXAMPLE
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
INFORMATION AND.
ONLINE HOW THE FUNDING NUMBERS
WERE CALCULATED AND HOW IT
ALIGNS TO THE TENTATIVE ON
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. WE WOULD
NOTE HOWEVER THAT IT IS NOT
QUITE CLEAR TO US WHY THIS
PROPOSAL IS ACTUALLY SEPARATES
FROM THE LAST ONE THAT YOU
CONSIDERED.
YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS IN THIS
MANNER THROUGH A WEB PORTAL. ON
IS A PRIORITY IT'S UNCLEAR TO US
WHY A PORTION OF THE FUNNY COULD
NOT BE DIRECTED SPECIFICALLY TO
THIS PURPOSE.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FROM ALL.
MEMBERS IT WAS A STOP TO US JUST
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT EFFECT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE.
THE ACCOUNTING SEPARATE ON THIS
BECAUSE OF WERE WORKING TO
DEVELOP A WEB PORTAL I THINK
THAT SHOULD BE. SEPARATE FROM
THE THE MONEY THAT'S GOING INTO
SELF HELP THAT ONE DOES HELP THE
OTHER AND WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT THEM IN THE SAME
CONVERSATION I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH THAT. BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOCATE THE NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT THE ONGOING MONEY
THAT. WHAT WAS THERE PLUS WHAT'S
BEEN ADDED AND DECIDE WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND THAT ON A WEB
PORTAL THAT COULD EAT UP THE
MONEY THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
USE? FOR THAT.
THE PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SO I WOULD JUST.
GRACE OCCASSION ABOUT DIPPING
INTO THESE FUNDS AND KEEP THEM
SEPARATE.
OKAY ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
WHEN I ASKED ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO CHAIR THE MEETING
I GOTTA GO DO A PRESENTATION.
YOU LIKE AUTHORITY OKAY.
WITH THAT IT.
YEAH.
NUMBER FIVE.
THE COUPLE TO DISMISS
SPACECRAFT.
SO WE'RE HOLDING THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU.
BUT THE OTHER THAT I AM FIVE
THEIR SUMMER COURSE THAT I'VE
MADE BUT THERE'S ALSO AN ITEM
SIX
PSYCHO PRESENT FROM HERE IF YOU
DON'T WANNA.
OKAY DISMAY SANTA THEM ANYWHERE
YOU WANT ALRIGHT. US GO FROM
HERE SO IF YOU'RE HERE FOR ITEM
SIX AS WELL JUST STAY WHERE YOU
ARE.
SO IN IN LINES.
I'M BACK AGAIN ASKING SOME OF
THE SAME THINGS ASK FOR LAST
YEAR I DO APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE.
REALLY FOCUSING ON ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IS AS.
WE HAVE PRESENTED.
THAT PART OF MY A ASK IS LOOKING
AT THE SELF HELP FUNDING WHICH
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT. HOW THE
TWO ASPECTS OF IT AGAIN FROM
ASKING THAT WE REQUIRE COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY LAW COURT?
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT FAMILY LAW
ARE PRIMARILY SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS AND WITHOUT HAVING A
RECORD IT'S VERY DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE. TO APPEAL OR
REALLY TO EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THOSE DECISIONS WORK AND I THINK
IT'S PART OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE AN
ADEQUATE RECORD IN FAMILY LAW
COURT AND I WOULD LIKE. THIS
COMMITTEE TO RECOMMEND THAT WE
FUND FULLY FUNDS
AT LEAST IN FAMILY LAW COURT
THAT. THAT WE HAVE.
COURT REPORTERS
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO TO ACCESS TO
JUSTICE.
THE OTHER ONE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK IS THAT WE INCREASE THE
EQUAL ACCESS FUNDING.
LAST YEAR WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING A TEN MILLION DOLLAR.
OVER TWO YEAR PERIOD EQUAL
ACCESS TO TO JUSTICE FUNDING.
A MATTHEW FOR THAT.
THAT THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
BE NOW MADE PERMANENT SO THAT WE
HAVE OUR OWN GOING GUARANTEE OF
AT LEAST TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
PLUS AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LEGAL
SERVICES FUNDING.
WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STARTING TO
TO SIGNIFICANTLY BACK OFF ON ITS
COMMITMENT. TO LEGAL SERVICES
FUNDING AND MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
PRIMARILY OUR. LOW INCOME.
LITIGANTS COMING OUT OF AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THOSE
ARE THE FOLKS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO AUGMENT
WITH SELF HELP CENTERS AND
OTHERS.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THOSE
ATTORNEYS OUT THERE WHO ARE
NECESSARY WHETHER IT'S
IMMIGRATION CONTACTS OR ANY
OTHER CONTACTS THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED. LEGAL ACCESS
TO SERVICES.
THROUGH FOR THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S THE
DIVISIONAL BUDGET ASK MAKE THE
TEN MILLION PERMANENT AND THAT
I'M ASKING FOR AND THAT WE
INCREASE. THAT OF THE ABOUT THE
BY TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS YEAR SO THAT WE CAN GET.
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE BACKLOG OF
ACCESS TO. TO LEGAL SERVICES.
AND YOU HAVE ANY.
WITNESSES OR IT'S JUST ME ISSUE.
OF.
FEATHER ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ITEM NUMBER. FIVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE BUDGET PRIORITIES.
MORE THAN A COUPLE OF PEOPLE.
ONE.
HI AGAIN SELENA COPELAND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LEGAL
AID ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDED MATERIALS AND PAPER
COPIES HERE BUT ALSO SOME
ELECTRONIC COPY TO JENNIFER AS
WELL. THERE'S A COPY FOR ALL
MEMBERS AND FOR STAFF.
AND SO I WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE REFERENCE WAS REALLY AND
THE NEED FOR INCREASED STABLE
FUNDING FOR LEGAL AID HEARING
CALIFORNIA. I'M OUR
ORGANIZATIONS RIGHT NOW SERVE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CLIENTS PER YEAR WITH THREE
SERVICES ALL THE WAY UP TO
REPRESENTATION NICK AT. AND AT
AT SETTLEMENTS AT TRIAL AND
APPELLATE HEARINGS BUT THAT'S
REALLY JUST ONE PIECE OF THE
ICEBERG AS WE SERVE MANY MORE
THROUGH SELF HELP SERVICES
THROUGH EDUCATIONAL NO YOU'RE
RIGHT PRESENTATIONS AND OTHER
KEY PRESENTATIONS. BUT IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
QUALIFY FOR FREE LEGAL AID BASED
ON THEIR INCOME LEVEL BUT ONLY
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND LEGAL AID
ATTORNEYS TO SERVE THEM. TOOK
QUITE A CASELOAD AND AND IF YOU
THINK THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A LEGAL
PROBLEM EACH YEAR YOU'D BUTTE
AND FORCEFULLY BE WRONG. OF A
RECENT NATIONAL STUDY SHOWED
THAT ABOUT SEVENTY ONE PERCENT
OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE CIVIL LEGAL A PROBLEM
EVERY A CIVIL LEGAL PROBLEM
EVERY SINGLE YEAR MANY OF THEM
MAY HAVE MORE THAN ONE PROBLEM.
AND I'M IT'S USUALLY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ON ISSUES OF THEIR
HOUSING OF VETERANS BENEFITS
ISSUES ISSUES OF ACCESSING
SERVICES HEALTH ACCESS. AND SO
LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS ARE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO STEP IN AND HELP THEM
BUT ONLY IF WE HAVE THE FUNDING
TO ACTUALLY HAVE ATTORNEYS OF
THE OFFICES TO SUPPORT THEM.
AND.
EIGHTY SIX PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO HAD THOSE LEGAL
PROBLEMS ACTUALLY WERE UNABLE TO
GET AN ADEQUATE OR ANY LEGAL
HELP AT ALL. SO AND WE DO
SUPPORT THE INCREASE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ONE MINUTE. YEP KEVIN AS THE
CHORUS OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS THIS STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BOTH PROPOSALS.
THAT WOULD BASICALLY MAKE ME A
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
M. PARTIALLY MEANINGFUL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TIFFANY RESERVOIR I AM A LEGAL
FOLLOW WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. MY POSITION IS
FUNDED ARE MOSTLY THROUGH THE
EQUAL ACCESS FUND AS ARE OTHER
EAT POSITIONS WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION THAT ARE FUNDED
ENTIRELY THROUGH THE INCREASE
EQUAL ACCESS FUND. SOME OF THE
WORK THAT I DO IS IMPACT
LITIGATION AND.
FACILITIES TO HOUSE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES
ARMED WITH A CONDITIONS IN
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE MAKING
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE. WE
ALSO AND.
DO INVESTIGATIONS INTO JUVENILE
HALLS AND IN JAIL FACILITIES
WHERE WE HAVE DETERMINE AND SOME
FACILITY IF.
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR ABUSE
NEGLECT PEOPLE DISABILITIES. AN
ADDITION TO ALL THAT WE HAVE.
WORKED WITH HUNDREDS OF CLIENTS
OVER THE LAST YEARS OF CREEPS
FUNDING.
TO PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES FOR
THEIR LACK OF ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND MEDICAL CARE AND
DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY
ENTITLED TO.
THAT FUNDING HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THESE NECESSARY SERVICES
FOR DIVERSE. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TREVOR
YAN THEM HOUSING ATTORNEY AT THE
LEGAL AID SOCIETY OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY AND I WANT TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE INCREASE. IN FUNDS
FOR ACCESS TO JUSTICE IS FUNDS
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO AMONG OTHER
THAT PEOPLE TENANTS ARE FIGHTING
TO SAVE THEIR THEIR HOMES IN THE
ELECTION PROCESS.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER MEMBERS KEVIN
BACK OF AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MR STONE'S REQUEST
FOR INCREASED FUNDING AND EQUAL
ACCESS FUN IF YOU YOU IS NOT A
RECIPIENT OF THESE FUNDS BUT WE
UNDERSTAND VERY WELL. HOW THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE SUCCESS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ON SELF HELP IS ON A
USEFUL SERVICE CHANGED HIS ME
FOR THOSE WHO CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT BUT?
SELF HELP BY SERVICES AROUND
COULD NOT PROVIDE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE
YOU'RE NOT LAWYERS
SO THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T MAKE USE OF
SELF HELP SERVICES AND NEED A
LAWYER TO ASSIST THEM. AND WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CAROLYN
DASHER NAM THE PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER LOCAL
SEIU SEVEN TWO ONE. AND SEES
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTS I REQUEST
A PHONE CALL REPORTERS AND OFF
FAMILY LAW CASES. IS NAPS NOT
ABSOLUTE DENIAL OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IF CALIFORNIANS WHO COME
TO COURT OR DENIED THE ACCESS TO
A COURT REPORTER AND ACCURATE
TRANSCRIPT.
A FEW YEARS AGO MANY COUNTIES
CHOSE THE LAYOFF COURT REPORTERS
AND WHAT THEY SAID WAS A COST
SAVING MEASURE AND THIS HAD AN
ADVERSE EFFECT ON THE PUBLIC.
AND I AM AN OFFICIAL REPORTER IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT ALL LOS ANGELES
COURTS DO PROVIDE COURT
REPORTERS. FOR FAMILY LAW CASES
AND OF LOS ANGELES CA DO IT THEN
THE REST OF THE COURTS CAN DO IT
TO THINK.
US YEAH YOU SEVEN TWO ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSE
PADILLA ON THE STATE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE WE HAVE EIGHTEEN OFF
THE STRUGGLE CALIFORNIA PROVIDES
CIVIL LEGAL AID.
A TO RURAL POOR LIKELY
FARMWORKERS.
FOR THE RECORD I WANTED TO.
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WEBER.
A AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE FOR
PREVIOUSLY.
SUPPORTING E. AJ FUNDING
INCREASES
AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CONTINUES TO DESTABILIZE
NATIONAL LEGAL SERVICES.
STATE FUNDING IS BECOMING MORE
MORE MORE CRITICAL AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE RECORD CHAMPIONING
THAT. AND FOR THE RECORD I
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL MADE BY
SOMEONE STONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GARY
SMITH I'M THE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WOULD PROVIDE FREE LEGAL
SERVICES TO POOR COMMUNITIES IN
TWENTY THREE. MOSTLY VERY RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
WHERE THERE ARE VERY FEW OTHER
LEGAL RESOURCES.
BUT WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE'S OF
BOTH OF HIS PROPOSALS
PARTICULARLY THE PART OF THE.
I HIS EQUAL ACCESS FUND PROPOSAL
THAT WILL MAKE PERMANENT THE
CURRENT. TEN MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN PROVIDE A MEASURE OF
A BUDGET STABILITY ON THIS ISSUE
GOING FORWARD TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
REPRESENTING TRIAL COURT
EMPLOYEES AND THIRTY SIX
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT BOTH OSAMA SOME REMEMBER
STONE'S REQUEST PARTICULARLY THE
ONE WITH REGARD TO.
COURT REPORTERS IS SUCH A SMALL
INVESTMENT TO MAKE SUCH A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF
LITIGANTS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION SHANE GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF I'VE AYE FPT LOCAL
TWENTY ONE WE REPRESENT.
COURT REPORTERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HAVING COURT REPORTERS IN
FAMILY LAW THERE ARE VERY FEW
MATTERS IN COURT THAT ARE MORE
IMPORTANT AND.
MORE VITAL TO HAVE A GOOD
RECORD THEM FAMILY LAW MATTERS
SO SPORT PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH.
REPRESENT THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE'S PROPOSAL TO HAVE A COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY COURT WHILE
WE HAVE OUR ISSUES IN ORANGE
REPORTERS IN FAMILY COURT AND WE
THINK THEY SHOULD BE IN COURT
STATEWIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE ALSO WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
TO REQUIRE COURT REPORTERS IN
FAMILY COURT MATTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
KAREN KIESLER ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHICH
REPRESENTS COURT EMPLOYEES AND
MERCED IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALSO
FOR THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY COURT
EMPLOYEES SOCIALIZATION. AND
DEPUTIZED BY LIBBY SANCHO'S FOR
LABORERS US SEVEN NINE TWO IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION.
WE SERVE LOW INCOME FARM WORKER
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HEARING SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE EQUAL
ACCESS FOR JUSTICE FUNDS. IT IS
VITALLY NECESSARY
TO HAVE LEGAL SERVICES FOR LONG
LOW INCOME DISADVANTAGE RURAL
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO ANGELINA OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS
ANGELES AND THONG SUPPORT OF
ASYLUM PERCENT POTTER INCREASE.
THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND AND MY LA
AFFILIATE HAS RECEIVED FUNDING I
FROM A HALF A AND BECAUSE OF
THAT WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES FOR A LOT OF THAT
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND LA REGIONS
AND CALIFORNIA REGION. AND A ONE
THIRD OF ASIA COMMUNITY IS
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT OUR
SERVICE THE.
PROVIDES A BILINGUAL SERVICES
LEGAL SERVICES FOR UP TO SEVEN
LANGUAGES AND INCREASE THE
DECIDED BEALL ALLOWS ME TO
EXPAND SO. MAIENSCHEIN SUPPORT.
I MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE TO SUPPORT THE.
PROPOSAL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE TO INCREASE THE FUNDING
FOR THE EQUAL ACCESS FUNDING
CURTIS COMMITTED TO SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN MANY WAS BASED ON
SEPARATE LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASING
AT EQUAL ACCESS FUNDS OUR
ORGANIZATION IS A RECIPIEN OF
THESE FUNDS ONLY USE IT. ON TO
SUPPORT A WIDE RANGE OF REENTRY
SERVICES FROM RECORD CLAIMS
CLINICS STORE FINES AND FEES
ADVOCACY THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT BEFORE SO WITHOUT THESE
FUNDS WE REALLY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO DO A LOT OF THE WORK THAT
DETAIL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR KIRK CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO THANK CAP MISTER STONE
AGAIN FOR CONTINUING TO CARRY
THE WATER FOR THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF INSURING THAT.
LOW INCOME PERSONS HAVE
ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES WE
ARE THE LARGEST RECIPIENT. OF
THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND AND AS YOU
HEARD EARLIER WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THROUGH SOME VERY GOOD
YOUNG LAWYERS LEGAL SERVICES.
IN OUR UP PROGRAMS AND FOR US
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE
ONGOING SO WE CAN KEEP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PROVIDING LEGAL
SERVICES FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HERE FROM THE PARA FINANCE.
OR
NOTHING.
HELLO. NOTHING.
ANY ERA.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LIKE MR STONE YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON YOUR I MEAN I THINK
THAT MIGHT BE SOME JUST ASKING
THAT IT BE INCLUDED IN OUR.
BUDGET THIS YEAR AND I
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU AND.
ABOUT A WHOLE BUNCH OF FEAR.
SO WHAT WERE THIS IS AWFUL ON
HOLD.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX.
IF OF ISSUE BRENT CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
ON MY CORNER DIRECTOR OF OUR
FACILITIES PROGRAM HERE TO
PRESENT. THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR OUR OUR
BUILDING PROGRAM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMAN JONES
SAWYER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
WHITE COURTNEY.
A VET YIGAL CLOSER.
SURE.
THE THE BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES
EIGHT PROJECTS OF FOR ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
LIMON FUNDING FOR THE.
CONTINUATION OF DESIGN IS
PROPOSED FOR THRILLS PROJECTS
AND FUNDING FOR CONSTRUCTION IS
PROPOSED FOR FIVE OF THE
PROJECTS.
THE YELLOW THREE PROJECTS
PROPOSED FOR ADDITIONAL DESIGN
FUNDS.
ARSENAL BUT CINEMA COUNTY
COURTHOUSE LOCATED IN SANTA
ROSA.
FOR ELEVEN POINT THREE MILLION.
BECAUSE.
STANISLAUS COUNTY COURTHOUSE
LOCATED IN MODESTO FOR FIFTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION.
AND THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
COURTHOUSE LOCATED IN MENIFEE
CALIFORNIA FOR FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION.
THERE ARE FIVE PROJECTS AS I
MENTIONED PROPOSED FOR
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING.
USING LEASE FOR LEASE REVENUE
BONDS
BOTH PROJECTS.
OR THE IMPERIAL COUNTY
COURTHOUSE LOCATED IN EL CENTRO
CALIFORNIA FOR FORTY ONE POINT
NINE MILLION.
SISKIYOU COUNTY COURTHOUSE
LOCATED Y. RICO.
FOR FIFTY NINE POINT TWO
MILLION.
SHASTA COUNTY COURTHOUSE LOCATED
IN REDDING FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION.
TUOHY COUNTY COURTHOUSE LOCATED
IN SONORA.
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION.
AND THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
COURTHOUSE LOCATED IN INDIO FOR
FORTY FIVE POINT THREE MILLION.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT THOSE
PROJECTS.
TODAY.
I DID ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
COMMENT.
.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY OFFICER OVER FINANCE
PROJECTS IN HOUSE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
AT THE TERM PROJECTS THAT ARE
PUT FORWARD ARE TENTATIVE TO
SEVENTEEN OF THE CURRENTLY
APPROVED LISTS THAT ARE.
FURTHEST ALONG THE MOST READY
TO START CONSTRUCTION IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
WHERE WHERE ARE AT WERE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE?
ELLIOTT'S RECOMMENDATION TO
REASSESS THE PROGRAM BEFORE ANY
FUTURE PROJECTS ARE RECOMMENDED
BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT WILL
TAKE TIME AND MONEY. ANDWE
STILL BELIEVE THAT THE TEN THAT
ARE PROPOSAL BEFORE WOULD STILL
BE THE TEN THAT WERE PROPOSED
BECAUSE THE CRITERIA THAT. PUT
THEM ON THE IMMEDIATE CRITICAL
NEEDS LESS TEN YEARS AGO ARE
STILL THERE AND IF ANYTHING THE.
A BILL THAT'S OF CONTINUE TO
DETERIORATE.
A WORLD WHERE THE DECLINING
REVENUE SITUATION ON THE SPECIAL
FUNDS WHICH SAYS SUPPORT THE
LEASE REVENUE PAYMENTS ON THE
CURRENT.
BONTA HAVE ALREADY BEEN SOLD
AND IT'S FOR THAT REASON THAT WE
RECOMMEND AT THE GENERAL FUND BE
THE SOURCE OF PAYMENT FOR THE OF
THE SEVEN ABOUT PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I WOULD THINK
IT'S PREMATURE TO REDIRECT THE
FUNDS FROM. A SPECIAL FUNDS TO
THE GENERAL FUND AZEGLIO HAS
RECOMMENDED BECAUSE EVEN WITH
DECLINING REVENUES THOSE. FUNDS
ARE SCHEDULED TO BE.
SOLVENT FOR THE NEAR TERM
FUTURE AND WE CONTINUE TO
MONITOR MONITOR THOSE FUNDS ON
AN ACTIVE BASIS.
BEFORE ANY FUTURE PROJECTS WE.
REQUESTED IN THAT WHAT IF ANY
FUTURE PROJECTS WERE REQUESTED
IN THE FUTURE WE WOULD DIE IF I
WITH THOSE AT THAT TIME WITH
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES AND
OTHER STATE PRIORITIES.
THANK LA A.
SO WE ARE PREPARED TO HAND OUT
WHICH I BELIEVE THE SERGEANTS
HAS DISTRIBUTED TO YOU.
AND SO USING THIS AS A GUIDE
FOR OUR COMMENTS TODAY.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE OF
YOUR HAND OUT WE FIRST PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE TRIAL COURT
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM. AND SO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
FACILITIES WERE TRANSFERRED TO
THE STATE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO AND JUDICIAL COUNCIL WAS
AUTHORIZED SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY IN THE ASSESSMENT
SELECTION AND CONSTRUCTION OF
THESE PROJECTS.
THERE WERE TWO ACCOUNTS THAT
WERE CREATED TO SUPPORT THESE
EFFORTS ON THEIR BOTH FUNDED BY
INCREASED BUT CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
FINE IF YOU REVENUES.
AND THE TWO ACCOUNTS OF THE
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND AS CFCF
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO.
AND A MEDIA CRITICAL NEEDS
ACCOUNT CREATED AND.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT OF
PARTICULAR NOTE RELATED TO
ECONOMIC JUDICIAL COUNCIL WAS
ACTUALLY PROHIBITED FROM
AUTHORIZING ANY.
EXPENDITURES THAT THE FUNDS
COULD NOT SUPPORT.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OF
YOUR HAND OUT.
THERE IS A LACK OF REVENUE AND
BOTH OF THE ACCOUNTS AND THIS IS
REALLY FOR TWO REASONS.
FIRST AS SHOWN BEFORE YOU ON IN
THE TABLE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE TEN A TOTAL OF ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION HAS BEEN RE
DIRECTED TO EITHER THE GENERAL
FUND OR TO TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS AND THIS GENERALLY
COINCIDED TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF THE FISCAL DOWNTURN.
TO DATE CURRENTLY FIFTY FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION CONTINUES TO
BE TRANSFERRED TO TRIAL COURT
OPERATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT'S DEPOSITED INTO
THESE ACCOUNTS HAVE STEADILY
DECLINED OVER THE PAST DECADE.
SO THIS LACK OF REVENUE THEN
LEADS TO TWO MAJOR PROBLEMS IF
YOU TURN TO PAGES AND FOUR OF
YOUR HAND OUT.
THE FIRST PROBLEM IS THAT THERE
IS AN INSUFFICIENT FUNDING TO
COMPLETE THE PLANNED PROJECTS.
AS OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
FOURTEEN PROJECTS TO BE FUNDED
FROM FC FCF HAVE BEEN COMPLETED.
HOWEVER OUT OF THE FORTY ONE
PROJECTS TO BE FUNDED FROM AETNA
ONLY TWELVE HAVE BEEN COMPLETED.
TEAM ARE ON HOLD AND ELEVEN ARE
INDEFINITELY DELAYED.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FIVE OF YOUR
HAND OUT THE SECOND MAJOR
PROBLEM IS THAT THERE'S
INSUFFICIENT FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OUR CURRENT OBLIGATIONS.
THE FOR EXAMPLE THE S. CFCF IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IS ESTIMATED
TO HAVE ONGOING EXPENDITURES A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN EIGHTY SIX MILLION
IN PROJECTED REVENUE LOSS.
SO BOTH OF THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
FUNDING THESE ONGOING
EXPENDITURES BY DRAWING DOWN
THERE FUND BALANCES AND BOTH
FUNDS ARE LESS EXPECTED TO
BECOME INSOLVENT IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
ABSENT ANY CHANGES AND REVENUES
ARE EXPENDITURES.
TURN TO PAGE SIX OF YOUR HAND
OUT I THINK THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
OF A GOOD JOB KIND OF
SUMMARIZING THE PROPOSAL IT IS
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN LEASE REVENUE BONDS BACKED BY
THE GENERAL FUND. INSTEAD OF
AETNA IF YOU LOOK AT THE TABLE
BEFORE YOU ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE THIS WILL MEAN ANNUAL THAT
SERVICE OF A HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SEVEN OF
YOUR HAND OUT.
WE GENERALLY FIND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS A
REASONABLE AS EFFECTIVELY IN
USED TO FINANCE PROJECTS.
HOWEVER WHILE THAT PROJECTS THAT
ARE SELECTED ARE THE CLOSEST TO
CONSTRUCTION IT IS UNCLEAR TO US
WHETHER THEY REPRESENT THOSE
THAT OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY. IN
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY WERE
SELECTED AND IT'S FAST ABOUT A
DECADE AGO AND THE LEGISLATURE
MAY HAVE SELECTED DIFFERENT
PROJECTS IF THEY WERE INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCLUDE A LONG
TERM SOLUTION TO ADDRESS KEY
PROBLEMS FACING THE SYSTEM. ONE
THE CONTINUED DECLINE AND FINING
FEE REVENUE. THE FACT THAT THERE
IS INSUFFICIENT SECONDS THE FACT
THAT THERE IS INSUFFICIENT
REVENUE TO MEET EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS WHICH CAN MEAN THAT
THE GENERAL FUND MAY NEED TO
PROVIDE NINETY TO A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS.
THAT WOULD BE ON TOP OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND FINALLY THAT THERE IS NO
CLEAR PLAN FOR HOW FUTURE
PROJECTS WILL BE FUNDED WILL BE
FROM THE GENERAL FUND OR. FROM
THE CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS WHEN
THERE'S AVAILABLE FUNDING.
SO TO ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS ANA
ONGOING BASIS WE ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND OVERHAULING THE.
AND OUR RECOMMENDATION HAS FOUR
COMPONENTS.
WE RECOMMEND SHIFTING THE
FUNDING FOR TROPPER PROJECTS
CURRENT AND FUTURE ONES TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT PROJECTS
MOVE FORWARD BASED ON
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES RATHER
THAN HOW MUCH FUNDING WAS
AVAILABLE IN IN THESE ACCOUNTS.
I WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CLEARLY AWARE OF
THE TOTAL GENERAL FUND
OBLIGATION THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO MOVE THAT PROJECT
FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY WE THEN RECOMMEND
SHIFTING THE REVENUES THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN DEPOSITED INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS TO MOVED
OVER TO THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT
THEY'RE STILL AVAILABLE TO
PARTIALLY OFFSET THE DEBT
SERVICE THAT WAS SHIFTED.
THIRD WE RECOMMEND SHIFTING THE
NON CONSTRUCTION RELATED
EXPENSES OVER AND APPROPRIATING
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
MAINTAIN THOSE SERVICE LEVELS.
AND FINALLY FOR ANY FUTURE
PROJECTS WE RECOMMEND THAT THEY
MOVE FORWARD BASED ON
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND AND
HELP THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE
WHAT THOSE PROJECTS WOULD BE WE
DO RECOMMEND A REASSESSMENT OF
THE PROJECT.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE NINE OF YOUR
HAND OUT IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
NOT INTERESTED AND OVERHAULING
THE SYSTEM. WE DO RECOMMEND
MODIFYING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND FIVE WAYS TO AT
LEAST MAKE SOME IMPROVEMENT.
SO THE FIRST IS TO CONSOLIDATE
THE TWO ACCOUNTS TO ENSURE THAT
NO PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD UNLESS
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT TOTAL REVENUE
TO SUPPORT THEM. AS THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY REDUCE GENERAL FUND
BACKFILL THAT'S NEEDED IN THE
FUTURE.
SECONDS WE RECOMMEND TERMINATING
THE ANNUAL FIFTY FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSFER FROM THE
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS
TO TRIAL COURT OPERATIONS AND
INSTEAD PROVIDE THE ROUTE THOSE
RESOURCES FROM THE GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD.
THIRD WE RECOMMEND TRANSFERRING
A HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS WHICH IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
CONSOLIDATED ACCOUNT.
BUT REQUIRE THAT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ADDRESS ANY EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS BEFORE ANY NEW
PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT WOULD BE
UNCLEAR HOW MANY NEW PROJECTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD.
FOURTH WE DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO SUBMIT A LONG TERM
FUND CONDITION STATEMENT WITH
ANY FUTURE FUNDING REQUEST TO
DEMONSTRATE. THAT THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT REVENUE TO MEET
EXISTING OBLIGATIONS IN ADDITION
TO ANY NEW ONES.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE
RECOMMEND.
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO REASSESS THE
PROJECT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PROJECTS THAT ARE OF
HIGHEST PRIORITY ARE ACCURATELY
IDENTIFIED.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE. FOR IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE RENEWED
INVESTMENT AND QUIRK
CONSTRUCTION.
THE REASONS OBVIOUSLY ARE.
CERTAINLY THE IMPORTANT ACCESS
TO JUSTICE FOR COURT USERS BUT
ALSO IT'S IN RECOGNITION. OF THE
VERY MANY WAYS IN WHICH COURT
AND COUNTY FUNCTIONS STILL
INTERACT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THERE ARE
LOTS OF COUNTIES FUNCTIONS THAT
ARE DEPENDENT.
OR INTERTWINED WITH THE COURT
FUNCTION AND FOR THAT REASON WE
SUPPORT SAFE NEW AND MODERN
COURTHOUSES AND IN PARTICULAR
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT THIS
YEAR THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS HOME.
YOU DON'T GET MUCH BETTER. YET
THANK YOU OPEN ARM.
ACTUALLY I AM VERY INTERESTED IN
AND AND THIS AND YOU'RE KIND OF
IN MY WHEELHOUSE RIGHT ABOUT
NOW.
I MISSED A FORMER DIRECTOR
RELEASED A FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND VERY FAMILIAR FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE DEUKMEJIAN LAW
BEACH COURTHOUSE.
AND THE COST OF BUILDING THAT
I'M VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY.
WE'RE SPENDING NOW NOT ONLY NOW
BUT.
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE GOING UP.
AND IF FOR.
SIGH WE WERE GOING TO TRADE WAR
WHICH CERTAIN COUNTRIES IT COULD
GO UP EVEN MORE.
SO I SEE WE HAVE PROJECT EVER
INDEFINITELY DELAYED.
I I WROTE WILL ASSUME THAT MEANS
THAT'S WHEN WE GET AROUND TOO
LONG OR WHATEVER WE FIGURE OUT
WE GOT MONEY.
AND.
I'M I'M KIND OF LEANING TOWARD.
NOT ONLY OVERHAULING
BUT REEVALUATING EVERYTHING THAT
WE CAN DO AND IN TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE CAN DO. IT WE CAN'T
DO ON WITH THE MONEY THAT WE
HAVE. AND THEN DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT WE WANT TO GO FORWARD.
AND SO I AM I.
I'M GOING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION.
ON.
LIKE YOU MENTIONED THAT WOULD BE
IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY GOING INTO
CERTAIN FUNDS.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS HAD INITIAL.
ESTIMATE IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
TWO THOUSAND TEN.
AND I WOULD IMAGINE WE'VE BLOWN
THAT BUDGET.
WHAT WAY OVER THAT THEM IN MOST
OF THAT FOR? CONSTRUCTION COSTS
AND ANOTHER THING SO.
GOING FORWARD EVEN IF YOU WANT A
PLAN THAT WE NEED TO.
TO REALLY LOOK AT THE.
THE RISING COSTS OF OF MATERIALS
AND CONSTRUCTION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND SO I'M.
IF IF SOMEONE COULD COME IN MY
OFFICE I WOULD LOVE TO.
GO OVER THESE FORTY TWO
PROJECTS.
.
I'M ASSUMING SIXTEEN ARE HOLDERS
SIXTEEN THAT WE HOPE. ONE DAY
YOU WILL BE ABLE.
TO DO.
AND WE ARE A CANCELED THREE.
SO I.
THESE COURTHOUSES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT GET THIS DONE.
SO I THINK WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
LEGISLATURE WORKING TOGETHER.
THEN WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH PLAN THE OTHER THING OUT
JUST
LIVE WITH THAT AND IN THE CITY.
.
I BUILT SEVERAL POLICE STATION
FIRE STATIONS.
ON LIBRARIES.
AND WHEN WE.
DECIDED NOT.
TO HAVE THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
BE THE PROJECT MANAGER ONLY
DECIDED NOT. TO HAVE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT BECOME THE PROJECT
MANAGER OR LIBRARIAN.
AND KIND OF LOOKED AT OUR COSTS
AND AND CON A CENTRALIZED
EVERYTHING BUT MORE IMPORTANT
HAVE STANDARDS FOR OFFICE SIDES.
WE SAVED ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
ULTIMATELY WERE ABLE TO COME IN
ON TIME.
AND UNDER BUDGET.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
THE THOUGHT PROCESS THAT WENT
INTO EACH OF THESE BECAUSE I
HAVE A FEELING. EACH ONE HE'S
BEEN TREATED YOU MEET.
AND YOUR OWN WAY ON HOW THE HOW
THE BILL THIS AND.
AND I THINK THAT MAY BE PART OF
THE THE PROBLEM OF BUILDING WHEN
YOU.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENGINEERS.
WHO ARE OBJECTIVE LOOKING AT
THESE PROJECTS AND MAKING
DECISIONS?
NAM.
CAN BE.
CAN BE LOW PROBLEMATIC I
REMEMBER TALKING ABOUT THIS WHEN
I FIRST GOT HERE TWENTY TWELVE.
AND THEN I WAS TOLD THAT THE
JUDGE WAS IN CHARGE OF LOOKING
AT IT AND COMING UP WITH SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN WORK WHERE PROJECT MANAGER.
BUT THE LEAD TO STILL.
WITH LOT OF JUDGES HOA.
I DON'T.
BELABORED ANYMORE BUT I WOULD.
LOW AND I KNOW WE'RE HOLE
HEDONISM HOLE. BUT I WOULD LOVE
TO.
WE GIVE SOME ADVICE SOME INPUT
ON THIS.
AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND OBVIOUSLY OF
THE ALLELES POSITION IS VERY
INTERESTING AND AND WE.
MAY NEED TO LOOK AT IT MORE
CAREFULLY IN TERMS OF.
BLENDING THE RESOURCES TOGETHER
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON AND HOW
IT'S FINANCED.
.
I WHEN I ASKED ABOUT THE.
THE ONE THAT ARE RECOMMENDED THE
TEN COURT HOUSES THAT ARE
RECOMMENDED WHERE THESE OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY IN TERMS OF
NEED IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW SPACE
AND YOU KNOW OR SOMETHING
FALLING APART WHATEVER I DON'T
KNOW. I WAS TOLD THAT THEY'RE
PROBABLY NOT OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY.
OF THAT.
I AND I DON'T KNOW MAYBE THEY
ARE BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT IT BUT BUT I
WOULD ADD IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
CONDITIONS OF EACH ONE OF THE
COURTS I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF THIS IS.
IF THESE ARE HYPER HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR CONSTRUCTION.
.
YOU KNOW I'D I'D I'M INTERESTED
IN THAT I HATE TO MESS WITH THE
LIST WITH I KNOW HOW THAT IS YOU
KNOW THE NEW KID ON THE BLOCK
COMES IN AND THOSE LIST THAT THE
WINDOWS. MAKES A NEW LIST AND
THEN GET BUILT ANOTHER PERSON
COME LONG PUT ANOTHER LIST
TOGETHER SO. I I THINK IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL AND MAYBE YOU ALREADY
HAVE DECIDED THAT THESE ARE.
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY VERSUS
THOSE THAT WERE ALREADY IN LINE
THAT WE MADE UP OUR MINDS DO YOU
KNOW I MEAN.
SWEET A WILD GUESS SINCE THINGS
HAVE TAKEN PLACE I KNOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO GIVE NEW
COURTHOUSE ENABLE JUST GOT A NEW
ONE. AND I KNOW IMPORTANT AND
HOW IT GOOD IT FEELS OF EVEN THE
WE DON'T KNOW WHY WE GOT IT
SOMEBODY SAID SOMETHING HAPPEN
AND THEREFORE WE. END UP GETTING
IT BASED ON SOME.
PROBLEM THAT EXISTED IN THE OLD
COURTHOUSE I I DON'T WANT TO GO
UP ANY SKELETONS BUT.
BUT I'D BE INTERESTED IN
KNOWING WHETHER NOT THESE TWO
AND HOW THEY RANK WITH OTHERS OF
OTHERS SO. IF WE'VE GOT THESE
OTHER FOLKS KIND OF THE SIXTEEN
HANG OUT HERE HOW DO THEY FIT
PLAN AND THIS IS REALLY
ADDRESSING.
YOU KNOW THE NEED THAT WE THAT
WE HAVE TO.
.
BASICALLY PROVIDE JUSTICE FAIR
IN AND CONDITIONS WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT A DECENT
CONDITIONS AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT.
I DON'T KNOW.
.
IS THERE ANY ASSESSMENT DONE OF
THESE TEN PROJECTS BUT PROGRAM
ACCORDING UNJUST THERE WAS OKAY
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ASSESSMENT THAT WAS DONE STILL
VALID TODAY THE REST FOUR
CRITERIA. THAT ALL THE PROJECTS
WERE PRIORITIZE WITH THE
CRITERIA INCLUDES IMPROVING
SECURITY OF.
SEPARATING THE IN CUSTODY
DEFENDANTS FROM THE PUBLIC AND
FROM THE COURT STAFF. OF
REDUCING OVERCROWDING COMMITS A
ANALYSIS OF THE ACTUAL SPACE IN
ACCORDANCE COMPARED TO OUR
DESIGN GUIDELINES FOR EACH
ELEMENT THAT A COURTHOUSE IS
MADE UP OF.
CORRECTING THE PHYSICAL HAZARDS
IN THE BUILDINGS
WHICH INCLUDES FIRE.
LIFE SAFETY ACCESSIBILITY
SEISMIC IN AN OVERALL GENERAL
CONDITION OF THE BUILDING ITSELF
PROOF MECHANICAL EQUIPMENT
ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT.
THEN FINALLY IMPROVING THE
ACCESS TO COURTS SERVICES WHICH
IS AN ASSESSMENT.
OF OF THE ACTUAL WORKLOAD ACTUAL
JUDGESHIPS IN THAT PARTICULAR
COURT.
HONG AGAINST A FORECAST OF WHAT
THAT WORKLOAD AND FORECAST WHAT
THE JUDGESHIPS MIGHT BE FOR THAT
COURT.
SO THOSE CRITERIA WERE WERE EACH
OR THE FIVE POINT SYSTEM
DEVELOPED WITH EACH OF THOSE
FOUR RIGHT TO ARM.
ELEMENTS BEING EQUALLY TREATED.
THE HIGHER YOUR SCORE WAS THE
HIGHER YOU WERE ON THE LIST FOR
REPLACEMENT.
ALL THE BUILDINGS THAT WERE IN
THE BUDGET TODAY AS PROPOSED OR
EITHER LISTED AS A MEDIA OR
CRITICAL.
AND AND WE DID REASSESS THAT.
QUICKLY HERE JUST AS THE BUDGET
WAS BEING PROPOSED AND DETERMINE
IT'S STILL THE SAME.
ADDITIONALLY.
FIVE OF THOSE PROJECTS
ARE COMPLETELY DESIGN.
ALL THE A WE HAVE ALL THE
APPROVALS TO CONSTRUCT CLOSE
SOME OF THOSE WERE ACTUALLY IN
THE BUDGET TWO YEARS AGO WHEN
THE.
.
FUNDING CONDITION OF THE EGGMAN
A REQUIRED US TO STOP THEM.
OKAY COUPLE THESE WHAT ARE TO BE
DONE OR NEARLY COMPLETELY HAD WE
NOT HAD THE FUND.
ISSUE WITH THE ACCOUNT WHICH
WANT OF A BETTER READY TO GO. OF
ALL THE PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THE
BUDGET FOR CONSTRUCTION. OKAY
WHICH EARLIER PROJECTS THE END
OF THE.
IMPERIAL COUNTY EL CENTRO
SISKIYOU COUNTY WHAT RICO.
SHASTA COUNTY REDDING.
TUOHY COUNTY SONORA.
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY INTO INDIA
THOSE PROJECTS ARE ALL FULLY
DESIGNED WE'VE APPROVALS FROM
UP I WOULD ALSO NOTE.
SO WE SPENT ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE EAST
TEN PROJECTS TO DATE FROM PRIOR
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATIONS TO
ACQUIRE LAND. PERFORMS THE
DESIGNS.
REVIEW THE BUDGETS ALL THESE
PROJECTS WENT BEFORE RADIO.
OF OF SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE COURT
FACILITIES ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AND ALL THEIR BUDGETS FOR
REDUCED AND THAT ACTUALLY OPENED
REDUCED OF.
POINT TEN AND TWENTY PERCENT
DURING THE DESIGN PROCESS
INCREDIBLY HAD A FUND WILL FUND
ISSUE AND WE DID NOT WANT TO
INCUR MORE LONG BEACH TYPE
PROJECTS.
OKAY SO YOU SAYING THEY'RE
BASICALLY FIVE OF THEM THAT ARE
THAT WE HAVE.
THERE REALLY HAVE PLANS AND
EVERYTHING APPROVAL. AND
LANDESMAN PURCHASE THE OTHER
FIVE HAVE THEY PURCHASED LAND
AND EXPENDITURES JOBS AND MADE
ON THOSE AS WELL OTHER BEEN LAND
ACQUIRED AND DESIGNED DEVELOPED
FOR ALL OF THE OTHER PROJECTS
ARE IN THE BUDGET AS WELL OKAY.
OKAY.
ALL TOTAL FOR THOSE PROJECTS
WHICH IS MEANT ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
HAVE YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS OF WITH REGARD TO THE
COMBINING OF THE FUNDS THAT CAN
THE FUNDS I WOULD THE FOR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON. ON THAT
A PETITION HAS DIPPER OFFENSIVE
JUST REITERATE WHAT WE MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT.
WOULD THINK IT'S PREMATURE TO
COMBINE THE FUNDS BECAUSE EVEN
WITH DECLINING REVENUES THEY'RE
STILL SCHEDULED TO BE SOLVENT
FOR THE NEAR TERM FUTURE.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THIS ITEM
ASSAILED OPEN AND WILL OBVIOUSLY
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS IT.
BUT I THINK THAT INFORMATION
GAME WAS VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND SOME WOMEN JONES
SAWYER BE HAPPY TO MEET WITH YOU
TO GO THROUGH THE ACTUAL DETAILS
OF. EACH PROJECT ON THE FOR LOVE
THE FORTY ONE BUT IN THAT AND IN
THE FUTURE PROJECT AS I'M SURE
ALICE ONE MAKE SURE WE CAN GET
ALL DONE GOODELL. REGRET LEAD TO
GREAT.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE TODAY THANK
YOU FOR.
.
THIS INFORMATION CONCERNING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WILL BE HELD OPEN
ALSO.
AND IF THE CQ DISINFORMATION
WILL MAKE SURE WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THAT.
.
HAVING NOTHING